B
Main ass.
You know what, let's start off with a big bat.
That's great.
Okay, this is going to be annoying.
Well, 15?
Yeah.
Does not head.
What are you doing?
We're losing.
I'm up to 10 feet to an unoccupied space.
You can see delivered spectral claw attack that deals lashing force damage.
You choose when you cast the spell.
Make a melee spell attack against it on a hit.
Okay.
As TIGOR, you take charge for once and you leap through and try to claw him.
You see these metal rods that he's holding in one of his hands just appears in front of
your eyes as your claws just strike it and you reel back.
Oh, no, kitty.
Let's not get impatient here.
I'm talking to my brother.
All right, that's your turn.
Do you have anything else?
I'm going to use up on this.
I'm going to use this spell.
I'm going to use up on this action.
This is going to be annoying.
I'm not using to playing your cast or for a clause.
You sprout wicked claws that you can use an on strike to deal damage with grow.
It deals 1,6 instead of dealing the normal damage to your on strike and you can use your
spell casting ability for the attack.
Do you deal this, you gain temporary HP equal to your spell casting modifier.
Okay.
How do you do it?
He already has the claws on his droplet side just imagine that.
Yeah, they just seep HP, I guess.
The claws start to, I guess, he just tightens the claws, I guess, at this point.
I don't know what to do with it.
Okay.
Next is Riff.
What are you doing, Riff?
Go ahead.
Yeah, Robert Shardken.
Click on midi attack.
That's 20 attacks.
Okay.
Right now both of you are literally right in front of him and Tigor you've moved in to his
like 5 feet range and Riff you're just shooting from where you were standing.
Yeah, let's see if you're here Tigor.
This is not letting me move to go or so that's why I couldn't.
That's max damage.
Can you not move?
Oh yeah, it's not your turn.
That's why you can't move.
Yeah, it's max damage.
You're just want to make sure I have everything because I always forget about my
fucking reactions.
You see if I have any reactions as Riff you shoot the shells, Robert Shelds from your
gun.
Some of those shells pierce these dangling like metal rods and hit him as he reels back.
Looks at you and you've got tricks now.
Don't you?
Yeah, that's going to hit him.
All right, what else you got?
Inspired you or I just wait by seeing you on that your bar found inspiration.
This is the bar of the inspiration.
All right, Tigor you can use a 1D6 die.
Hip hip hooray.
Next is.
Next is Riff.
He looks at everyone.
He goes.
It's useless isn't it?
To make you understand what you've run into.
I tried brother but I guess I'll have to tell your parents the bad news as he clicks.
As he.
I mean cousin brother is the same thing.
He clicks on like some of the buttons on his side and that's going to be not a pattern.
Okay, can all you make a.
Listen to.
Hip hip.
Both of you saved.
Okay, at this point you initially what you saw the rods dangling from above the room.
They all drop down and they start to move around you in a pattern and blocks you from going outside.
They just start moving vertically as in like a storm outside brewing.
That's it Tigor is your turn.
There's no escape now little kid.
Are you going to run?
Um, you use your phone to delete more of the text.
That's that.
I start swinging.
Nice.
He started blasting.
That's going to hit.
Hey.
What was it normal damage?
Oh, that's just the conflict.
So you didn't have to use that then.
I guess for the temp HP.
Yeah.
Get it.
Bad damage.
But I do get the.
You do damage on the track.
You can number of temporary hit point equal to your spell casting ability modifier, which is.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
I thought he lost the fucking.
I don't already.
Okay.
How many do you get for?
Uh, okay.
As Tigor, you jump in and try to slash him.
He slides away, but his arm gets nicked.
It looks down at you.
Go.
Stay the fuck down.
You much.
And he's going to attack you next.
Uh, riff.
What do you do?
Tigor, you want to do something else?
Let me check my bonus actions.
I have no bonus.
If you have a small med kit.
That'll be all.
That will be all.
All right.
Riff.
It is your turn.
Yeah.
What can be bold?
Give me a concy.
All right.
I'm just going to tell you this right now.
As you strum your guitar and the wave of a sound, which just hits a riff, he goes, you really
didn't think I would not prepare for this brother as he pulls like ear buds from inside his ear,
but it's just a bonus to be all very aware of how you fright.
No, it's, it's flavored as deafness.
You can't use blindness for this.
Only deafness.
You can do anything else if you want to.
It's just for flavor.
If I can only use a fucking deaf disability.
Let me re-fund that.
There you go.
As the waves hit him, he says that and then you have some time to do something else.
I think I used the wrong gun control for as time, but how?
Wasn't it 1.8?
1.8 plus 2 plus 1.
Was it Thunderwave?
Thunderwave?
It's essentially sound again, but it's fine.
Then he couldn't do anything.
Yeah, but for the first one, he will say that.
All right.
19, he saves.
Do half damage.
As the first one did not hit, the second one hit so hard that it just pierces the years anyway.
What was damage?
Six.
Okay.
As he reels back from the attack, he looks down at T-Gor.
And, oh, Consafe.
He saves.
He looks down at T-Gor.
You can't go out of the thing, Cloud Laggers.
Oh, sorry.
If not a pattern.
You're going to stay inside.
I know, I know, but flavoring wise, it's like metal rods going around.
It's basically caging you in.
Yeah, I know, I know.
All right.
He will look at him and he will do, do, do, do, Cloud of daggers.
As those daggers that were surrounding you are all coincide and start to hit T-Gor.
The daggers just turn around and just embed in them and T-Gor.
Do you have a reaction, T-Gor?
I don't think so.
No, I don't.
All right.
So, if you have a reaction, you will get hurt.
If it enters, no.
If it enters the cube, or ends it turned there.
If the cube moves into its space, creature takes a diamond one per turn.
So you've taken the damage, you can move outside.
Yeah, it's your turn.
Ends.
As all those blades stab into you.
I took the damage.
I am concentrating on this.
Can make a concentration save.
You should have popped up on the zone.
I don't think it applied the damage to me.
It did.
14.
The four got removed and then the next.
You're not concentrating and see you concentrating.
Which is a concentrating one.
I don't think I actually had to do it.
It is concentration.
You had to do the emperor's class.
I don't know if you should do the emperor's class, but it's fine.
Just make a normal standard roll down there.
B20.
Yeah, you said.
Okay.
What do you want to do?
So since I am concentrating already, that means I keep the any concentration on a wild shape,
we're going to be formed.
Let's go.
Just click on transform.
Wow.
As you go, you put your hand inside your bag and you pull out the mask and just put it on.
And you just drop down to all fours.
I don't protect.
Let me cut.
As you don't the mask, you turn it around.
That was my action.
No, it's a bonus.
Is wild shape an action?
No, wait.
Yeah, no, it's an action.
It is an action.
What?
Well, that's your action.
I guess you just do that and move around.
All right, riff, you're turned.
You can move around the whole place.
It should be around like 120 feet all throughout like a circle.
That's not enough for me.
So you can get close to him.
I'm going to say that.
I know.
He's just going to stay away and shoot.
He's not a loose.
Yeah, I know.
He misses.
As you shoot your guns, the blades, they're still circling around him.
They're just going to knock him away.
Are you not tired of the same plan, brother?
Is his turn?
He's going to turn around.
Wait a second.
What?
I have a bonus action.
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Is he waiting anything metal?
He just the metal rods around him.
He's not himself wearing any.
He's also not a whole metal.
You can use the heat metal to heat the claws.
That would do damage to him, then.
No, no, no.
I don't think you can just do that.
No, no, it's just that he's metal so you have to drop it.
Oh, I mean, we can change it.
That's fine.
Is it touch or is it arranged?
Is that me damage?
Yeah, yeah.
So that's short work.
All right, he metal how much damage does it add?
2d6?
It does 3d8 damage.
2d8 damage.
Okay, for the next turn, T-Gore, as riff, like, strums as a guitar, strike of electricity
just strikes your claws as they heat and you understand what he's trying to do.
For the next turn, the metal is heated in your arms.
You also still have Bardic, so if you miss --
Yeah, you also have Bardic, so if you miss, you can also do that.
Sent at this point.
Oh, my God.
Why can't I open a character sheet?
Because he's already dead.
Or that's sent, sent.
There you go.
He's gonna --
Check.
Fuck, it's cold.
He's gonna turn back and he's gonna look at you and he goes,
not now.
A little thing.
He's gonna cast Shatter.
Make a concept.
T-Gore.
As the daggers all just collide into themselves as a shock wave just burst through.
And let's see if that downs you.
That's three.
That's insane.
Yeah, that's normal.
Yeah, all the ones, Jesus.
As they ping around into you the cause in your hands, you duck and you're ready to strike.
What do you do?
Okay, so he has multi attack, Cade.
Yeah.
Two attacks.
I don't know why I said one.
Okay, three.
Roll of Amperec died twice and then on top of that you'd roll 36.
For the heat medal.
38.
38?
28.
Okay, that's fine.
I was like, what the fuck, bro?
I think I messed something up.
Just click on -- if you go on your spell book, what happened?
The spells are gone.
I'm just going to use all your spells.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'll just say that you have a wall shot.
There's nothing else.
It's just the art.
It's different.
Yeah, that's fine.
I didn't add the --
Okay, just to make sure I'm doing this right.
This is the spell book.
Go to spell book, go to Amperec clause and click on MIDI Damage.
Okay.
Yeah.
There.
Okay.
Now click on MIDI Damage for the Damage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now it's working.
The concentration's showing up.
Two swan.
No, no, no, do you want to do the Wampric Clause Damage?
I have to attack first though to see if it lands.
Oh, you see.
So Wampric Clause only does the Damage -- oh, yeah, yeah, attack.
Okay, I see.
Now it's not letting me click on the attack.
See?
Something's wrong.
No, no.
Just go to inventory, click on Cloud Gauntlet and then MIDI Attack.
I'm refreshing really quickly.
It might be a bit slower than before, but I switched some shit.
And I hope my pie does not explode.
Loading power.
Okay.
You want to work now?
Yes.
Does not hit.
Gold attack.
I can't do that.
That's going to hit.
We're going to do the Wampric for the first one then.
I'll minimal damage.
I'll do the heat metal at the end.
That's going to hit.
Regular damage for that.
All right.
Is 28 for the heat metal?
Yeah, both times.
So 48.
Yes.
Cloud of Dagger is gone.
19.
Damn.
Okay, T-Gore, as you slide in as he blasts a shockwave towards you, you just
pass and just claw both of your claws right in his chest as the metal heat radius through
his body as his screams turns around looking at his body, often blood as his chest starts
to bleed.
He got some tricks on your hands.
All right.
That's your turn.
Do you want to do something else?
Just though we're properly doing stuff.
I'm just going to put them back in the transform just so it's.
It's a spells.
Yes, the spells are gone.
Let me just move the spells from your base sheet to this.
I think it's just the spell thing that's broken.
I'm going to just drag drop all the spells in.
There we go.
Cade.
Cat's brain evil eye animal friendship speak with animal beast bond full cloud.
Yes, and this.
Yeah, there you go.
You should have all the spells now.
All right.
Now you're off your turn.
Yeah.
Robert Schell.
Well, it does not hit again.
You try to shoot him at this point.
The cloud of daggers start like assembling behind him.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Calm down.
You do another bardic inspiration for?
Yep.
Look to go.
Okay.
What do you say?
How is it looking?
Oh, how is it?
How is it?
What's the space?
T-Guard.
T-Guard looks fine.
He looks very determined.
Oh, riff.
The synth.
Sorry.
The synth does look damaged, but he does not look like.
He has given up.
Just keep.
Back here.
Just keep punching his face.
All right.
Let's move on.
It's since turned and he's going to.
I've had enough of this.
And he's going to.
Get him out.
I've had enough.
He's going to cloud daggers on you.
He's going to.
He shouldn't be.
He shouldn't be as careless.
Just because I'm hurt.
He just slides his hand as all these like metal rods.
Just start to go toward you.
And.
I didn't get rid of them before you take damage.
Well, no, because he has on the yellow.
Or medical damage.
He's rushed to stabbing into your arm and legs.
3333.
Now how do you like that?
Let me see what else he got.
I think that's going to be his turn.
It's your turn, Kegor.
It's going to hit.
Holy shit.
He's eating more than I think he would.
That misses the operation.
Yeah, that's going to hit.
This will roll the damage twice.
Max damage nice.
Was it none max?
No, it's a D8.
Do I still have the heat metal?
No.
As he jumped back in, as he's reading away from you,
you stab him in the hand arms again.
Wait, what the fuck happened?
You just go wild.
Yeah, I don't know why.
This is because you target a U.
Selected.
Five.
Concentration again.
Was it nine?
Yes, select.
There you go.
It's going to use Barting Inspiration.
You casted Barting Inspiration on him?
What did you do that for?
No, no, you casted it on him accidentally
because I got the option to use Barting Inspiration for some reason.
I always press target and then choose.
Anyway, his concentration is dropped.
That's cool.
Good job.
You're doing it.
As Tegor, you slash into him twice again.
Do you have anything else?
I think that's all your actions.
You want to roar?
Roar.
You're turned.
Should have been more than a first-level spouse.
But there's no this.
He only has two.
He only has two first-level spouse.
Let me check.
I made him like that.
That's why I gave him two-level spouse more.
You'll understand the NPCs are not exactly like peak form NPCs.
All of these things are not good.
You can train them when he's on the crew.
You shoot another one, the blades that just fell down, just get up again and redirect the shots away from him.
You just don't give up, do you?
Don't worry, I'll find her.
I'll treat her the same rampage that I'm going to flick up on you.
Alright.
Dig or make up shut up.
More exploration.
Just right click and target on T-Gore.
That's how you...
Anyway...
My headphones are connecting me one second.
I'm back.
Is that your turn, right?
It's Rift's turn.
I'm going to go back. I've had enough of this.
He's going to do...
You know... stay put.
No... T-Gore.
Yeah.
This is obscene wisdom saving, please.
You're going through it, should be fine.
You should be fine.
As these cloud of daggers essentially just surround you at this point and just pin you down.
All throughout your body, just do the ground.
You are now trapped.
And now we just have a good match.
I don't we, brother.
As he starts to walk towards you, just very fashionably.
Like this, I need a gun.
T-Gore is your turn.
How do you get out of hope person?
You don't.
Unless someone helps you.
Wait.
Do you have a spell to break out of it?
Well, it's only a D6, so that would be a max of a...
You do have bardic inspiration.
If you roll a 6, I think you can match it.
If you roll a 6, I'll let you get out.
But the bardic inspiration has begun, right?
Are you going to get out or no?
At the end of your turn, you can roll again.
I'll just wait.
Well, then you can roll again to get out.
Get out of hope person.
Okay, it's worse.
All right.
Why are you doing with Baptiste?
Because you have plus four.
It's only showing up plus three.
Why is Baptiste here?
Just select your token and then roll.
Now it shows up at six.
It was plus six.
You roll the six.
You roll the seven.
Then it was six.
You don't get out anyway.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah.
You can get out.
As you just grab these rods and just get them out of your body, you get up.
I think that's your action.
Rift.
Another wave.
As you strum your guitar again as a concentrated blast, just goes through.
I'm not going to do that.
So you have a manage.
Pounds.
I can one does it.
Both 1917.
That's crazy.
As you jump from behind and stab him with one of your claws,
you have to get rid of him.
He goes, this...
Hang still alive.
Is it gain 10 HP again?
Oh man, you're back at full HP.
How the fuck?
It's his human form that's got damaged.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I forgot.
Put the image in my back.
All right, is your return with Riff?
Yes.
Riff?
Riffing.
Oh, not 20.
As he's walking towards you,
you just spin your guitar to the other side and just start shooting.
Hold the damage.
It might be...
It might be enough actually.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so what do you want to do?
All right, it's just the moment he like steps up to me
and just put a much shorter gun in his face.
You spoke too much.
Okay, as this rubber gun hits him in the head
and he just falls flat on his back.
All right.
Is he done?
So what are you guys doing now?
What?
Yeah, yeah, let's do malphous.
I don't think you killed him, right?
Because the rubber bullet would not kill him.
What would Rick want?
What would...
At this point, Riff might not be able to kill his cousin.
Yeah, he just gets the keys from his pocket
and then you start to go up and maybe heal or recover.
Can I do a flavor thing for a Tegor?
Sure.
I know we told him to stop smoking.
So I was able to like alternative to smoke that's healthier.
He's just gonna put one foot on the guy's chest.
Just go bar.
Nice.
Riff just looking at him.
What are you doing?
All right, let's move on to malphous.
Let me move you guys here.
Don't remove the tokens.
Because I need to know how much the HP is at every point.
Oh, no.
All right.
Just forget about any of these things exist, okay?
Malphous, in this room, all you see are a bunch of statues
in different sets of armor, stone statues.
And right in the center of it, you see a guy wearing a heavy tank
kind of armor.
And he's putting his arms above this hammer
which is facing downwards toward the ground.
Kind of embedded a couple of inches inside the rock itself.
You see the rock is cracked from beneath.
And at this point, he's just waiting.
As soon as you get inside, he turns his head up.
As wiser, you see, he starts to glow red.
His body starts to the red circles in his body.
He starts to glow red.
As finally, the armor's wiser powers through a central line
towards his belt.
It starts to grab the hammer, put a grab a shield
from placed around his left arm.
Grab it, gets it up, takes the hammer, starts to walk towards you.
And he just asks one question.
Are you the one who killed my brother?
That dollar from metal?
I can't cure you properly.
You're real night soon.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
No, I think Baptiste killed him at the end.
So you wouldn't know.
It's my turn.
Sorry, sorry.
Let me go to level two.
I'll be a level one.
All right.
So, just go to private GM role.
I don't know if it works or not.
The map I don't think is necessary.
I mean, you know, what the fuck is happening?
Just so small.
It is very small.
Let me see if I can move you to something else.
Just let me move you to the fucking ocean.
I'm the ocean.
Just pretend it's like a rock floor.
That's him.
Where are you?
Where's the bus?
Essentially all around this room, like in a square,
the statues are lined up.
I still see the previous thing.
Yeah, let me move you here.
I'm standing in Congo.
Let me clear this comma.
Can I end it?
Create a new one.
Yeah, I can create a new one.
Here we go.
So, did he start?
Did you answer him or no?
You'll be reunited or something.
You'll be reunited soon.
Yeah, I didn't kill him.
Yeah, I know.
I was trapped.
As he starts walking towards you slowly, he goes,
I don't think so.
I'm taking you down because it's my duty and my brother failed in this.
I just want to know the person who killed him.
I bear no ill will toward anyone doing their duty.
As...
Fuck it, do your boss.
As the leader of House Trimmer, I will show you the true friends of the Emperor.
He's going to just start, normally start walking towards you.
What are you doing?
It's your turn.
Yeah, it is.
I should get a temperature beam because I'm a drunk master.
I get a temperature beam equal to the wisdom everywhere.
Is it not working automatically?
No.
Just remember to add it on your own.
Okay, let's go.
Let's pop a stance and see what we get.
People in whose veins stand.
Show me eight.
Oh my god.
I have no idea.
If an enemy creature within 30 feet of you makes an attack or attack you against any other creature.
That's what you got.
So funny.
Holy shit, that's a useless one.
Oh, it's all again next turn.
Is that your action?
That is your action.
Do you bonus?
Yeah, it is an action.
Oh my god, that was a worse one to get.
No, it says as a bonus action you can extend one spirit point to enter swinging stance.
So is it a bonus action or is it an action?
I'm looking at it.
It is a bonus action.
Yeah, it's a bonus action probably.
It wouldn't make sense for it to be an action.
Yeah.
It's a bonus action.
That sucks so much.
30 feet.
Oh, it's not your turn.
Sorry, I didn't begin combat.
All right, now you can move.
Oh, Jesus.
Okay.
As you swing around, let me see if he was it.
Let me check actually.
You're a good objective and see a blown in 10 foot elimination.
Oh, yeah, yeah, he has to cast it.
As you just burst in, I'm assuming you're doing charge attack right or just as you burst in your fist hits the shield,
but it somehow still is too heavy as it pierces through and hits his armor right in the chest.
Show me damage to the damage.
All right.
Okay.
It's your fist matches into him.
He reels back a little bit, but he still does not move an inch.
As you shuffle back to get some space between you and him, he keeps walking.
And let me see.
There you go.
And he walks towards you. He will at this point slam his hammer onto his shield as the red like energy starts to go around all his body.
I'm going to cast Sheila fate.
There we go.
And yeah, you're just slowly, slowly keeping up with you.
Let me check if he has any bonus.
Okay.
The same time he's going to cast this to enhance his current weapon, which is hammer.
That's his action and his bonus action.
Go ahead.
Just add your HP.
Remember.
Yeah, I didn't take damage.
Oh, you didn't take that.
I'm so annoyed that I'm fucking rolled the worst.
Roll three again.
Just jump off the building.
Not even try to fly.
Okay, it's a one.
Get a bonus to all damage rolls with weapon attacks and I'm striking to do bonus to damage attack.
You can bonus to all your damage attack and weapon attacks and I'm strike to.
I'm going to do bonus to all of your damage.
That's good.
I'm likely that's not about that.
That was my point of action.
Yeah.
23.
Okay, as you swing your arm again, unlike last time, he just raises up his shield and this time you just feel like you just hit a wall.
There is no impact.
Your arms start to hurt at this point that the ringing just goes through your arm to your body as you reel back with the pain as he starts to move forward and he goes interesting.
What is your name warrior?
It does not hit.
Yeah, I'm just rolling the shaking again.
What is your name warrior?
Malfus.
My name is baseframmer.
Let us fight to the death and he raises his arm.
I'm already doing that.
I'm moving back.
Oh, sorry.
I can't see you.
Get my turn.
Go ahead.
Go back.
I'm going to fight to the death.
As soon as he says that, you feel like a really reaction as you just go back.
And he keeps moving.
He keeps moving very slowly.
Step by step, the coming on the floor just gets louder and louder as he steps closer to you.
This time he moves closer than by the end of his weapon.
You start to see like a...
Let me see.
I can right click further.
Can I show his goddamn...
No, mine.
Can I not show it?
Okay.
Anyway, at the end of his weapon, you see this red thing starting to pump again, again, again, as he just points it at you.
And he's going to use...
Shatter.
As this beam of just base hits you right in the face.
Make a con save.
From the ocean coming forward.
Okay.
Let me check if this is the correct one.
I didn't change the fucking flavor of it, but essentially this is like a humming beam that just nails you down.
So the energy from the beam will just focus on you.
It's a constant ray of beam.
The initial impact will do the damage, but after that you will be just positioned there, unless you break out of it with a con save at the start of your turn.
Yeah, I don't fucking alter spells.
Damn, it's only five, one, two, two. That's crazy.
I'm not complaining, so that's only two damage.
And he's just going to start moving toward you.
Can you make a wisdom?
Sorry, con save again.
Yeah, yeah, you get out.
As you leap out of that humming energy, like sound beam, what do you want to do?
Right.
I think this is the moment that I don't sound as comic-com lose.
What's the base to a fucking thunderstorm strike?
As you leap off, the sound wave just immediately collapses as this dust cloud forms and inside of the dust cloud, you stand up and get out of the dust with your hair electrified, your body electrified and the feathers start to form on your body.
As he goes, a devil fruit user, I should have guessed so.
All right, action.
Action?
See, there's a bonus action.
Yeah.
Hello.
What's free to that 25?
Okay, as this time, you start to reel back and hit it with brute force with your enhanced speed. This time, you make it through the shield, evade the shield and hit him right in the armor.
It's also plus three damage.
It's lightning.
Lightning plus normal.
What was the damage type for the other one?
Blushening?
Yeah, I think you should have a Blushemaking for Charger.
There's another now.
So that's three.
Plus three.
So I'm going to say, I'm going to say it will be 22, right?
Yes.
Okay.
Big math, big math.
There we go.
I already dropped the concentrations.
I don't know what he's doing.
Oh, it's on the shield.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
The shield of whatever was it?
Shield of faith.
As you bash into him again, he goes, this is the first time someone pierced through my arm.
It feels exhilarating.
He just, the shield that he was holding up until this point, he just drops it and he just looks at you.
And he goes, no, time to get started.
And this time instead of just standing, he's just going to full sprint.
I just feel like I don't want to get hit by the guy.
Sorry.
This is turned right.
Let me see.
What was the distance?
Yeah, yeah.
He should be able to close it in.
Okay.
As he gets to you, as you're cornered by the walls of this room, he will just take his hammer.
And with his increased speed, you could not just anticipate it and he would just take his hammer and just slam you right in.
Right in your back.
This is also, I think, enhanced.
23.
It didn't enhance it with something.
What was it?
Magic weapon.
What does it do?
Plus one and damage rolls.
Plus one.
Okay.
All right.
As the hammer strikes you at the back.
Let me roll.
It's going to be eight.
He's going to use bonus action and divine smite.
Okay.
As the shockwave, again, this time from the hammer itself, just fucking fins you as cracks appear in the floor as a dust cloud rises up.
It's going to be six and then it's going to be another 12.
All right.
Can you make a story and save to see if you get out of the pinned position?
Well, I can't be that expensive.
Sure, sure.
Okay.
Acrobatics are athletics.
That's basically whatever you choose.
Fucking you can't pin me down, bitch.
Okay.
As the dust, dust clouds clears.
His hammer hits the ground as you already have gotten up and around him.
What are you doing?
Do we skip to the first?
I mean, I don't want him to keep waiting until he finishes, right?
Yeah, yeah, true.
Okay.
From the other.
Okay, okay.
Let's do that.
Okay.
All right.
It's time.
Uptaste.
Be mad.
Man of beers.
Okay.
All right.
I pause the fight for him right now.
Let's do yours.
You have any map requests this time?
Do you want to fight in the astral plane?
Let's fight in the astral plane.
Anywhere.
Just so we don't have like any clutter, I'm going to move everyone to the astral plane.
Oh, no.
I'm nervous.
I'm rolling in private GMR, correct?
What?
The roles are going private GMR.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I was playing some Pokemon tower defense this past time.
I see, I see.
Yeah, Malfa's was like, you should probably go to about T's for now.
And then we can switch back.
So I was like, yeah, you're right.
No, no, it's fine.
It's better if we do it this way.
So we have like like the enemy style, you know, skip that fight, skip that fight.
All right.
So you can go into the room, you see again, the light shining down on his elevated seat.
He gets up from there as he puts his pockets, puts his hands in his pockets.
And he starts to jump down and he keeps moving towards you as he says.
So here's the leader, huh?
Is that the role that has been passed on to me?
Yes.
And you are, I assume, the strongest of the bunch.
Well, if you're talking pure strength, I might not be, but I have some tricks up my sleeve.
And at this point, he takes out one of his hand.
He forms like a shape with a finger like a big circle.
And he looks through it and looks at you.
He goes, have you heard of a man in the Marines?
They call them all.
I don't believe I have.
Are you saying to him?
What?
Oh, no, no.
I have no idea who he is.
I've just seen some interesting footage of him fighting as he clicks on something
behind, like underneath his other hands pocket.
And you see, like, there's a projection, then, then, Mushi right behind him, as it projects something on the back wall.
And you see the, essentially, the historic records of the war that happened during the Unity event.
And you see the, basically, the war zone.
It's just a bunch of holes, completely, like, areas of the battlefield, complete chunks of it just disappearing from the ground and up, like buildings, like half cracked.
And, like, basically, like a shape or something, just nod through them without any sign of it left.
And he goes, well, the power interested to me by the...
Emperor himself is the power of mimicry.
Let me show you a taste.
As he looks through the hole that he forms with his two fingers, basically the space that he looks through that hole with just burrows through,
vises right past you, snips like some of your hairs as it goes to the back wall, and, like, a whole section of the back wall,
a giant circle is dug through, and it just... nothing happens, like, no, like, beam of energy, nothing is just gone.
It just disappeared from that place.
Now, let's have some fun, shall we?
Well, he's inside.
Alright. What do you want to know?
What's his AC?
It's his AC. His AC is 16.
He can tell by looking at him, he is wearing something underneath his shirt, but not a lot of armor.
Gotcha.
Alright, Rufu initiative.
Time to play the game.
Alright, let me...
Let me start the encounter.
Well, let's start off.
And let's just charge in.
Well, let me do this first.
So, as soon as he, like, does that move or whatever, that teaches his take off, well, not take off,
but he's like, "Oh, this is what we're doing."
Play him on, and then I'm going God's speed.
Alright. And then I am.
So, as soon as his flame appears, he just clicks his flame, and then essentially just snaps right in front of him.
That's how quickly he's moving.
Let's get a punch.
And then I'm going to go ahead.
Ooh, that hits him.
And that'll be my turn.
So, as he let me just flames on, because God's speed looks like he teleport straight into his face and just wins a punch, squaring his jaw.
As you...
Punch, or him riding his jaw, he...
Do you want to do a pushing one or do you just want to punch him?
Am I having activated my actual arm set?
No, I think...
Do you not have pushing at hack? Is it a monk?
I don't think.
Wrong or...
What pushing at hack?
Is it like part of a subclass? What am I thinking? Is it from the open hands? I think it's from the open hands.
Okay, now mine.
I just zoom in and just hit him right in the jaw.
He reels back a bit.
He looks at the jaw and...
He seems very surprised.
He looks at you and goes, "I guess you're not all talk then."
Well, I wanted to talk to you about something.
Remember how I said that the...
Bells, they don't really get hurt or no one can get to them and all that.
Well, I have news for you.
And he clicks on another thing right in his other pocket.
His other hand is still inside his pocket.
He clicks on another thing. These shutters that you saw when you entered the room alongside the room itself start to open up.
And you see these old rusted and broken huge bells lined up alongside of these.
He goes, "See every rebellion started with destroying the bell."
They thought this is a symbol of their strength, but we just raised their memories.
And we made them think they couldn't do anything. They were helpless.
And that's how they should be.
Doesn't make you laugh. Doesn't it make you feel happy?
These worms right beneath our feet as they should be.
And he, at this point, he will look at you and he will just go, "Now, how about you lie down for a bit?"
Let me... Oh my god, Jesus Christ. Why do all the NPCs have default and no spells?
Let's see, lots.
He's going to cast Hedios laughter on you. Can you make a wisdom save?
Yes, I can.
Okay, as soon as he said that, this unknown sound just gets in your head.
And you don't feel like obeying, but you just find yourself lying on the ground, just held.
Nothing is stopping you, but it just feels weird. It just feels like you have to obey.
And he turns around. He gets up around you right toward your face.
Oh god damn it.
Sorry.
As you're lying down, oh my god, Jesus Christ, move, dude.
And just crouches down, gets up at your face from above.
He goes, "Well, this is just a sliver of the power my Lord gives me. How about we have some fun?"
Let's bet.
How many of your people do you think will survive this?
I say, maybe two. No more two.
And more will be a reward. So this bet, so to speak.
Only bet when I know there's going to be a profit.
Okay, that's going to be end of his turn.
I think you can make another DC check to get out right.
Or wisdom save.
Yeah, Tasha is a dyslafterist. I think you can get out. You have to make another every time on your turn.
One of your choice. Okay. At the end of each of its turn, each time it takes, it makes another wisdom.
Yeah. At the end of each of its turn, so at the end of your turn, you can try to get out.
Oh wait. Did I not do the damage? God damn it. Sorry.
On a fail to incapacitated.
At the end of each of its turn, and each time it takes damage, okay, never mind, never mind.
Yeah, yeah. No, it's not damage.
So you have to end your turn, and then you can do the save.
It's always the same.
Yeah, you get out. He's still right in front of your face.
And he gets in again. And this time, this feels weird to you, but he puts his hand in this pocket of,
like just just air. He puts his hand in the air and he takes out this sword at this point.
And then you send back to the first time you fought with Black Hand. And you saw him reaching out inside just like this.
And he whipped out a Black Blade and shrugged you with it.
So that's what you were expecting, but he just pulls out a normal rape here. And he goes,
I don't think you're in position to demand anything from me, Vermin.
And he's just going to stab you right in your arm.
There you go. All right, it's your turn.
If he bolts a tech, he did just that. He did, he did 23.
I can't see your olds then. Oh, I have it on private too, I guess.
Yeah, but you roll 23 and tag for 23. I think if we do private, then I can only see him.
Like, like I can see yours.
It's a GM.
So let's go ahead and you know, you have been really disappointing today.
You say you want to bet, but don't want to put up stakes.
Then you do what you just did.
My expectations were at a high. You just keep saving to not keep them.
And then as he finishes that, it's not going to form.
Right, let me do the modifications.
And let me do the tech save.
Yeah, as soon as the RnSturder to form, they just show up with this explosive wave.
And yeah, he's that's going to throw him 10 feedback to the wall.
Yeah, he failed the next. Do the damage.
I think he hits the wall and he's going to take a damage.
And then I'm just going to charge in once again, snapping to with my speed.
There it is.
One more.
As you smash through as an attempt of this guy even trying to use black hands technique,
you just smack through the wall.
And right now you're facing like your face is right in front of his.
Oh, are you mad?
Is this something that belonged to your friend?
And he's going to, this time he is going to use the same thing again.
But this time it feels different.
It feels heavy as he pulls out this black covered blade and just hits you right in the chest with it.
What's happening?
Hello? You good?
Oh my god, he failed.
Did I cut out for a second?
Yeah, he not one.
Okay, as he holds out this black blade, it just doesn't seem he's able to conjure or like keep track of all of this energy as he slashes.
But he just completely misses a target. But the wave of that slice slices through the back wall as half of this tower essentially just gets cut.
And the building starts to collapse from that part.
I said it once and I'll say it.
I'm not angry.
I'm just highly disappointed.
It's your turn.
I'm not going to lie. He did a good chunk of games last night.
You see, there is something that you'll never understand about.
You know, you're not going to be able to get out of this.
You're not going to be able to get out of this.
But you do your legs. Each time they come to the same result.
You don't belong in power.
If you did, you would have resolved this before all this until like point to all the bells in the room.
The fact that they've rebelled this many times shows you don't deserve your power.
So I'll show you what true power is meant to be utilized for.
Turn into my elemental body.
Let's swing again.
I did it correctly this time. I even targeted him.
As you swing once again, the guy, what you said last time,
it kind of seemed to have picked him off a bit.
Another one of those.
You're going to lecture me and say that these good people deserve any better.
They do not stand a chance.
They should stay in the mud of where the bill long.
I'm going to show you what disappointment feels like.
And he will do...
As he starts to dissipate from your side, he just disappears into a blur.
Nice, gone.
It's your turn, Baptiste.
I'm just looking at what I have.
The hockey we can use when we use our inspiration.
It's anything either observation, conquerors or armament.
But it needs to have a good trigger.
Conquerors, either if you're using for attack, it will coach your attack in the conquerors hockey.
Which is just like four flavor.
I think I'll just keep it four flavor, not actual damage.
So if you want to finish someone off with conquerors, that's better.
For armament, it would add plus three to the AC.
And for observation, it would add plus three to your AC.
And plus three to your damage attack role.
For armament, sorry.
For conquerors, I'd say you will be able to give out the energy of the conquerors.
To knock people out.
But that should only work for people that are below your level.
Right.
Below like two or three levels below you.
You disappointed me, get it again.
Now you're hiding.
This doesn't seem like someone who's in power should have to do.
It should be confident.
Not cowards.
And for my action, I'm just going to.
Just let it take the dodge action.
No, but anything else.
Bonus actions are really limited to right now.
And that will be all.
All right.
As you say that, voices start to echo throughout the room as he goes.
You have a lot of nerves saying that to me.
How about this?
How about you just walk off that ledger right there?
Make a wisdom save, please.
As your feet start to move toward the ledge, you stop yourself.
And you hold back.
You hear the voice coming from behind you.
It's your turn.
As I'm stepping that way and stop.
I'll just turn my head to where the voice was.
You really thought that was a knock.
Can I see him now?
Yeah, the invisibility would warm.
We're off as soon as he attacked, right?
Let me check, actually.
Gerritra invisibility.
Does it war off as soon as he attacks or no?
Curricure, you touch, become invisible.
Oh, you are a creature.
You touch, become invisible.
Anything in the target carrying is invisible as long as it's on the target's back.
Yeah, the rest of the rules are the same.
Yeah, he attacks you, so that's why invisibility war off.
I could do something fun or completely wrecked face.
Let's see.
Let's look at this.
I'm going to use my devil fruit and ability.
One of my devil fruit is the cast face on myself.
Okay.
Let me move.
Why does it not let you do it?
Just don't just don't just don't.
Malphus has it.
I don't know why why you don't have it.
I just need to unclip consume spell spot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So just remember you have only three uses or two uses of level three.
I don't know.
Two right now.
Okay.
Let me cast haste on you.
There you go.
That gives me another action.
Swing with one.
Miss.
And then bonus action.
Another swing.
Oh, wow.
That's my turn.
Don't you have another action?
Oh, yeah, you cast it haste.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for God.
Okay, basically he's still invisible, but as because you know where the voice is coming from,
you can hit him.
But yeah, that's not going to be hitting him.
As you essentially feel like you see his like silhouette kind of you start to punch it.
You punch it again.
And it just does not land anywhere.
It's his turn.
As he goes, do you have fun swinging around?
How about this time?
And he, this time the invisibility completely disappears.
As you see him forming like a giant like shape right towards you.
And he's going to cast the same spell again that he casted in the beginning of the round.
Make a concept, please.
That one.
Okay, roll again.
Okay, that's three.
He is going to completely, literally obliterate you.
Thirty four.
Does that knock you out?
No.
Okay, okay.
As he forms the shape, you see him stand right in front of you.
He goes play times over.
He forms the shape as a hole just starts appearing right where your liver was.
And just you're completely the mass from that area is completely gone.
Just a sheer hole like in just a chisoon.
That that hole is essentially formed.
But you can still move.
You can still it didn't hit like any of your essentially wider organs.
You're standing through the pain.
But yeah, you're still still up.
As the blood pools around you at this point.
Nice.
As these arms start to dissipate, but reform again.
You see that came at the perfect time actually.
Because you said we full heal once we make our condition.
Yeah.
I have one thing left to fulfill my condition.
Why do you have a hundred walk?
Is it because of haste?
Haste and God's feed.
Oh, I see, I see.
I saw that when I was like looking at me, but that's insane.
Yeah.
I would like to use my inspiration.
Okay.
Let's do armament.
You said that plus three to attacks.
Yeah.
Just see two attacks plus three to your defense as well.
If you want to defend using it, but if you want to attack, yeah, use that.
Then I'm using it for my attacks.
All right.
The last requirement is using an unarmed strike.
Yeah.
Using that.
That all that hits without the inspiration.
We get two attacks because I'm paste right now.
So the text is action.
That also hits.
The only action attack.
This one might have inspiration used on it.
No.
Okay, three of them back to back all three attacks land.
Why am I giving you that damage?
It doesn't matter, bro.
You have plus ten.
Doesn't fucking matter.
Okay, 2016 and 17.
Let me do the math.
All of it is force, right?
Yes.
I believe it's 53.
53?
Yes.
Okay.
Tell me how do you do it?
This whole chunk of your body is missing.
What what happens?
So like, as you go that.
I'm really from the pain.
Obviously because I'm like.
I'm going to go to HP.
So.
Is it possible?
I could use.
Okay, you said conquer is hockey is just flavor.
So I'm just going to.
If I didn't need the army, I'd switch to using conquerors for this.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead.
Like,
that's something I'm like,
reeling back.
I like,
regained my posture.
It makes you know,
like,
the aura of the conquerors hockey just starts surrounding me.
I'm using the actual attack.
All of them converge.
And just unload on him.
With a single head.
Yeah.
Okay.
As this energy starts to drum drum around you, the rocks on the floor start getting up.
As this energy.
Start to swirl around you.
You're all of your arms start to combine into one this black orb of just power emanating.
And soon enough in like a single second,
the fist just goes right in his chest and throws him all the way through the room toward the back wall.
And that does.
53 is crazy, brother.
Hmm.
As.
What is does he had concentration on suggestion?
Okay.
As he just slams into that wall.
And at this point,
you see his eyes just glazed out completely, not out.
All right.
We're going to stop here.
I'm going to go to Malfus and continue his comeback.
Can I do something real quick?
What?
Is he not going to knock?
No, no, no.
We stopped midway.
You want to do something?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
I'm going to use a key point to do another punch, but nevermind.
I'll, I'll wait.
If you want to do another punch, let's go back and we'll just add the damage if you want to do that.
Because if I do another punch, then it makes sense because all four are ass or I'll just add the damage.
Roll another one.
And if it doesn't hit, I'll just say using the inspiration you do.
Yeah.
Do the attack.
Boom.
Roll max damage and the next one.
Max damage of the first die.
I think we were moving ahead with that, right?
Or no?
Okay.
Should I just roll quick damage and then we'll cut.
Just roll quick damage and I'll add the max damage to the first one.
Okay, let me see.
So the second one was not one.
So let's just add the not one to the max, which is eight.
So that's seven plus this.
So that's 24 plus seven.
So 31 more damage.
Holy shit, Jesus Christ.
Okay, okay, okay.
All four ass or arms did end up hitting.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Matt Quenny is crazy.
The last that this is meant to be, man.
I don't know what to do.
All right, I'll be back.
All right.
All right, Melfus, let's go.
Let's go back to the grandline in the middle of the ocean.
Like we're all the mood.
Yeah, there we go.
All right.
It was your turn, right?
Go ahead.
But smack you turned around and got out of the space.
What do you want to do?
Through his armor.
And he has metal.
I got a map there.
That's it.
24 does hit.
No much normal damage.
It's three damage.
And as this small spark goes through his body and goes,
is that all you have?
I refuse to believe that all you, let's see,
that is all you have, Melfus.
Couldn't fight like a man and stop running away.
All right.
His shield is still up.
Do you want to move?
Oh, by the way, he dropped his shield in the center of the room.
So he has less AC now from before.
Which is not that much honestly.
That's it.
Let's go with that.
12.
Let me open up his shield.
All right.
We're moving this time.
Room is pretty big.
It's like 120 feet.
You can move through him if you want to move here and then here.
Do you want to do?
As you get around the corners of this armor,
you start the shocking grass and hit the armor from behind,
punching through the thick height of it.
He still turns around.
Doesn't feel like he's been affected by it a lot.
He just turns around.
He starts to dash toward you at this point.
Not like dash in action dash.
It just runs.
Run straight up.
He raises up his weapon again.
And he's going to cast Shetter once more.
As this wave of energy hits you again.
You're out of it.
The damage initial blunt attack will definitely hit you.
I'm going to upcast it by one.
Let me roll another.
Oh, one D8.
That's seven.
Seven plus five.
12, six.
As this wave hits you again, but this time you're ready,
you just run away from the shockwave that is generated.
And get out of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, three again.
Sorry.
I'm 37 and I remove the three from there.
Yeah.
All right, it's your turn.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Yeah, I was sure.
You know, I'm also going to shout it.
Okay.
Why not?
Yeah.
I think it's the business or the season of Shatter.
This.
I was so much.
No.
Mix.
It's just like sound based.
Well, the minor minus under based.
Under is sound, right?
Well,
because lightning is lightning.
It's like a.
I'm just trying to say my friend is bigger.
Mine is like more impactful and louder.
It's my natural thunder and he's just like a bitch, right?
Yes, he's just on speakers, but mine is like from the gods.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like actual like lightning thunder.
Yeah, I see.
But it's still like the damaging thing is still essentially thunder.
I was or sound.
Okay, please.
Yes, that one will have an I think he's going to save anyway.
Yeah, as this.
As you just essentially shoot like a shock wave of hundreds
through your fingers, it hits him, but he does not seem affected
by it a lot, but it does hit for a shit ton.
Holy shit.
Yeah, remember your beauty one one one.
Yeah, oh my god.
Bro, you would not believe what happened to me.
About the keys right now, but Jesus Christ.
I'm not even making it up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that.
What else?
Oh, his shield dropped.
You see this whatever the wave that you threw at him messed
up with the mechanics of the armor as the red glow starts to
dissipate from his armor.
Yeah, you know, the other corner.
Yeah, I'm not going to use that.
Sorry.
He at this point will just keep his eyes on you as you start
to like run around these statues.
He just looks at you.
He goes, I see this is your way of fighting then.
No matter, I will keep up.
And he again just full sprints towards you.
The armor walking towards you.
And he's going to do.
Shatter again.
Wait, let me check if Tundra's one mid self.
Rathful is one mid self.
He's going to do Shatter.
I was going to upcast it by one again.
Can you make a wisdom save?
Again, the, sorry, how concept.
The shock wave just lands on you again.
Yeah, you say that again.
Again, you get out of it, but you do take.
Well, one, the eight again.
Oh, this time it's more 25 plus 227 divided by two.
That's 13.
13. So just remove then.
I'm just not going to remove the fucking temp bro.
What the fuck is the point?
Yeah, just remove any speed.
Yeah.
Yeah, just as the laser lands on that area again.
This time again, again, causing a blast as it collapses after you get out of it.
The same the statue that you were standing right against.
Can you do a perception?
Okay.
You get around and get out of the shock wave essentially.
That's going to be his turn unless he has.
Yeah, he can't do one to your target.
It's just melee.
It's mouthless.
Yeah.
That's the left side.
I remember something nice.
Moving.
Moving plates.
Nice.
Let me give you the Bowen blade.
18.
Okay.
What is Bowen blade?
What do you do with it?
I don't know.
What else do you want to do?
Bowen blade again.
I need to attack first to move forward a little.
Have this.
How long does the stance last?
10 minutes.
A minute.
I think it's been five.
It shows up here.
It's only been five.
I'm not going to do it.
I think the pattern around me are just starting to glow and park out.
I'm basically charging myself.
If you work with it, I could.
I can use it to make a range spell to the.
Okay.
And it's a observation for.
You apply it on you or do you plan it on enemy?
Well, no.
It's basically you choose a creature in which we can scan yourself.
I can.
Why is that used above the target?
So you're it's on you, right?
Yeah.
And if someone within my range of within the range of 60 feet of like which I use,
attacks someone you can choose to attack with the cloud.
Okay.
Essentially during this time as you're running around,
you are like concentrating these charges in the air of this place in a way that
it starts to form like these thunder clouds in the arena itself.
And these thunder clouds are like trying to like starting to like take form at this point.
So you were doing this from the very beginning of the fight.
But now they're starting to take form.
It's base is turned.
No, I'm moving.
Okay, move.
Can you move when you don't hit?
Yeah.
I thought you had to head to mobile.
But mobile you can move if you hit or not.
Okay, okay, okay, for mobile.
Okay.
Yeah.
Where's mobile?
Oh, there you go.
Can you use dash?
You make a melee attack against a creature.
You don't provoke a mission attack.
You have to get your test or the turn.
Whether you hit or not.
Okay.
Cool.
Okay, where do you want to move?
Hey, you make my turn again.
Oh, yes, all right.
There you go.
Hey.
You weren't expecting I would say next one, right?
Yeah.
That's fine.
As he.
What did booming big go again?
Oh, oh, I got it.
As I constantly.
Moment damage.
Moment blade.
Boming blade.
Moment damage.
What is this?
Well, if the target which you cost the blooming blade on.
Uh-huh.
Good to move.
That would do damage.
Oh, I casted it on you.
That's why let me let me remove that.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I was trying to do it.
But then where?
Why?
Where is booming blade?
I don't see it in the effect thing.
Ah, fuck it.
I'm just not going to do it.
Doesn't matter.
Okay, it's basis.
I feel back.
It's.
30.
No, it didn't damage you.
Yeah, no, no, it didn't damage you.
I think you were at 27.
No, you have to apply the damage for it to damage, right?
Uh, I can check the damage logs.
Wait, yeah, you only took 10.
Uh, alright, up as you are getting away, he's going to this time.
Uh, you see something in his movement changes.
Okay.
This time you see the dissipating energy that was going away from his armor, focuses on its leg.
And he's going to just full speed walk, uh, just run, sprint towards you.
Uh, again, that's going to double his speed.
It closes on you.
As soon as you arrive at the corner of that place, he just takes his hammer and just smacks
his right in front of you.
And he's going to do his multi attack.
That's our multi attack.
Then he's going to hammer.
22.
15.
Does not hit.
15 doesn't.
He's going to use extra attack.
And he's going to attack again.
18 does head.
Oh, that's your AC.
So it doesn't hit.
And nine.
So the only one hits, where is it?
Uh, where is it?
22.
13.
Okay, why are you resistance to bludgeoning?
Wait, what?
Oh, why are you resistant to bludgeoning?
From.
What is on?
Ignite it?
No, it's a.
10 works height.
Yeah, height.
It's in.
Where?
Did we decide on bludgeoning?
Why would you have resistance to bludgeoning?
I think we decided on like three base damage and.
No, I think I only gave it 100 enlightening.
No, I think this is from before when I gave everyone bludgeoning session like in non-oreans
by default, you have to activate the thing to get bludgeoning resistance right now you don't.
So I'm just going to do total 13.
Yeah, just then Roma also had it because it also gave the same thing to you.
Did we?
Let me check, actually.
That would make it clear.
Yeah, because I also gave Roma like in this hybrid.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I see.
I see.
Yeah, yeah, I'll remove that for Roma too.
I didn't remember, actually.
Thought this was from before for Lunarion.
Wait, does the, let me check, actually.
Double fruit.
Do the zones get it or is it from the zone thing or is it specifically for each fruit?
I don't think zones by default have it, right?
Well, I think like the option of a mythical zone had it as well.
Let me check, actually.
Mythical zone is the fruit, double fruit zone.
Okay, let me check.
Full beast form and hands.
Mythical.
No, it's just temporary.
It points for medical zones.
That's it.
No, it's not.
I don't know where it's from.
I don't remember anymore.
That's going to do.
And it's full for me.
He had the option and gave that.
So I just probably just.
I see, I see.
I gave the hybrid.
Let me do.
What was it?
13 damage.
Yes.
Let me just go.
There you go.
Okay.
Can you make a deck safe to get out of it?
First of all, let me do the.
Yeah, do the cloud thing.
Let's see if it.
Oh, hopefully it has.
I'll just do five of those to see if it's,
because I would be the same.
And 20.
Oh, what's the damage on it?
48 48.
48 hundred, right?
Or lightning?
Lightning.
Okay.
Roll 48 lightning.
40.
Hey, guys.
That little dice.
So he hit it hit you three times.
So do you do three times?
Only once again.
It's a reaction.
I see, I see.
So the first one only triggers.
That's it.
All right.
As these light.
The thunder right above you starts concentrating at this point.
And starts hitting him in the armor, dig 16 damage.
But you have to make a deck safe to get out.
Let's save.
You fail.
Okay.
It's your turn.
You can try to do something.
You're essentially grappled, but you can try to hit him.
As you're trying to get up,
he just slams the hammer right down again.
Okay.
Guess I'll just try to get out.
Try it again.
No, it doesn't.
It doesn't work.
He this time, the sonic, you can feel.
You can only do the action, right?
You want to do bonus action?
No, I found the need to hit it.
I like first to do a bonus action.
So you start to feel the coming right behind your back
as the weapon is ready to shatter you again.
And he's going to take it back.
He's going to swing right up again and just slam you again.
This time, let me see.
Let me see.
Let me first check how much it costs.
I don't make a mistake.
Please make mistakes.
He's going to strike with the more hammer.
He's going to multi attack.
Oh, he won't.
Yeah, that hits.
And he's going to...
Wait, wait, wait.
I should put a bonus action.
I can't.
He's going to do an extra attack.
Oh, he won't.
And Divine Smite is bonus, right?
It's a bonus action, yeah.
He's going to do an extra attack.
No, he won't.
That's seven.
Let me roll the damage for the first two.
Damage.
Both max damage.
Holy shit.
I'm not dying.
Dice is not in your favor.
Let me see.
Where did it happen?
13, 26, 26 and 26 and 27, 26 and 7, 26 and 7.
Let me check 33.
Yeah, but you're knocked out of your this first.
No, no, it just...
It's not a wild shape.
I thought it's still a bird.
For the full...
For the full thing, it's a wild shape, right?
For transformation.
That's what they add to the game.
So it's still not above twice, correct?
It's not 60.
Yeah, you need 60 or something, right?
44.
He needed another 40 damage to completely kill you.
So you are...
Knocked out.
I'm gonna move to Baptiste.
Yep, I'll be waiting.
And actually, both of you move down to Lunarfold, actually.
First.
Yeah.
Hello.
How is everyone doing?
Are we having fun?
Absolutely.
Aren't we having fun, guys?
Baptiste.
Yeah, we are.
Uh-oh.
I'm not liking this tone.
Oh, this is like normal tone of words.
What do you mean?
Whatever do you mean, sir?
How dare you in sin way that anything untoward is happening?
I cannot.
I don't believe it.
Let me see if every round is okay.
All right.
It's been great.
It's been great, right?
Red Baptiste?
All right, it was fine.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
All right.
Let's get back to the original fight.
Who's going to grab the key?
Uh-uh.
Riff, what do you think?
Okay.
Riff, you move toward the limp body of what's his face?
Synth.
And you grab the key of his chest dangling from his neck.
You grab the key, you pull it out.
You start to walk away.
Tigor, you're also following him and you're trying to get up to the second floor as soon as you start to walk away. Tigor, can you give me a perception?
What?
Where do you use skills with the NPC she?
On the right side, on the right side, on the stat block. On the stat block, there's like a pop-up window.
Stat block and before that, there's expand sidebar. If you see it.
Oh, gosh, I got some paint here.
Do a perception and you have to drop down skills if they're not proficient, yeah.
Found it, found it.
Oh, what is that? 16. Tigor, as you're starting to walk away, you hear shuffling right behind you.
And you see, Synth is getting up. His body is completely limp, but he's trying to get up as he reaches down in one of the bags around his body.
He reaches down, he takes out a while and he turns it. You see a symbol on the while. It says 6/6.
As soon as he turns the back of that while, it starts to pop out like a needle at the end of it.
And this 6/6 rotates around as it forms into like an infinity symbol as he stabs himself in the neck.
And what you see next is...
Oh, God damn it.
You see as Synth's body starts to decay as the face starts to mold into like this face.
And his eyes start to glow yellow, ears pop out of his head and his jaw starts to break as this green liquid starts to run down his face as he just looks down at Tigor and grouts.
And we're back in it.
Oh, fuck off.
How long did we finish fighting?
Literally, literally like a couple minutes.
Not even a couple minutes. It's just as soon as it finished, it started again.
No time to rest or anything.
It will be in Wildsaid.
Yeah, yeah. You are in Wildsaid.
You're still wearing the mask essentially.
It's not like you removed the mask as soon as the fight was over.
Alright.
I see.
Right here. That's on me.
Alright.
Oh.
Can you put me back?
Oh, let me... I see. I see. I see what happened. I see what happened.
I went to the fucking window and not here. There you go.
His body at this point, his legs, you see like he's like maybe like three or four inches tall than before.
His body is shaped like a llama. Tigor, you would know what a llama looks like.
His face, his features match that of a llama.
That's the rid of a llama.
I mean, it's better than a mask.
He could be a nice exhibit.
It's turned.
Yeah, this is a fight. It's going to start with him.
It leaps. It runs into you.
Climb up on the wall like pushing away the wall and just leaps onto you.
Tigor.
Sorry. Was it fucking natural weapons?
I'm going to attack you.
To a voice.
The first one hits for six.
Switch back to the floor.
Oh, yeah, sorry, sorry. The second one hits for nine, nine and six.
That's 15.
He's doing damage now.
15 is this to your temp and 11 to your base.
Oh, my God.
As you see him as soon as he gets up and he transforms, he leaps around jumps and just smacks right into Tigor.
His hands at this point is very heavy and Tigor, you just roll down with the impact.
All right, Rift's your turn.
You do have the key.
Yeah, I know that's why I said this is cheating.
First of all, show me pocket sans.
Pocket sans.
Yeah, I know, I know.
Oh, pocket sans.
So what are you doing?
Is this blind him?
Sure, sure.
I feel like Rift's not pocket sans.
He succeeds.
As you throw some sans on his face, at this point, this guy is just feral.
The rots that are lying right behind you and around you start to resonate again.
And they start to get up.
Tigor's your turn.
I'm going to give him a bardic and head to the door.
All right.
Do bardic.
Yes.
I'm going to leave Tigor to die.
You don't know.
You haven't communicated that.
You're not.
I don't think we can outrun this.
Yeah, I don't think you can outrun this.
You know, yeah, fuck is learning.
You said it's a lamb, right?
Lama, lama.
It's prey.
Or Tiger like me, that's prey.
Okay, sure.
Sure.
We'll see.
There we go.
Nice for for the first time you didn't properly.
That does hit.
That does it.
Yeah, you can do the one empire thing if you want to.
Not much time has passed.
Maybe like 30 seconds at max.
I don't know.
I didn't target him.
Did I know?
Oh, that's fine.
There you go.
And for heel, let me give you the heel.
There we go.
What's the damage on the gauntlet?
Eight, five, five gauntlet, eight, eight, eight, eight.
Yeah, there you go.
I applied both damage.
Okay, as you, uh, Tigo or leap in, you slash, uh, it's like arm at this point that the
floats are like ripping apart from his body and you make him bleed a bit as you
reel back and start to gather yourself.
It's your turn.
Yeah, but risk.
There's no running from.
This point, this beast will look at you as it raises its arm and it's going to do.
Sorry.
And my SS.
I'm going to do.
These rods start to electrify and the energy between them starts to create the static field around
this whole arena is just lightning burst through from one rod to other and anything in between
will get hurt.
All right, this whole area is covered.
The creature that starts to turn the area of attack to D6 instead of acids is going to be
lightning and a creature that ends turn in the area of effect.
All right, there we go.
All right, the your turn, Riff.
Let me roll the damage first.
Can you make a dexave?
The dexave is only when you end right.
The creature ends its turn within the area missed.
I'm not rolling for.
I'm going to roll it again.
Any creature starts the turn in the area of effect and any creature that ends its turn in
the area of effect.
It's only start the turn.
At the end of the net you need to roll safe.
I say, so it's going to damage with all this for you for the first one.
You also cannot see anything at this point.
Let me do.
Sorry, I did Riff.
Riff is down.
He's a human determination.
He's not down.
He's at one.
Nice.
Yeah.
But essentially it does take you down.
You can get up next turn.
That's how we'll flavor it.
Or you can do something if you want to this turn.
Well, it just, yeah, it's my turn.
Oh, at the fuck out of there.
Okay, get out.
All right.
He gourds your turn.
Time for you to take some damage.
Time for you to die.
Oh, too.
Oh, yeah, your action.
Go ahead.
Uh, uh, uh,
Point.
He put himself in the.
It doesn't, it doesn't affect him.
Oh, good.
It should, but it's like a refliver.
It's not exactly hunger.
So fucking making your spells better.
What do you mean it's not better?
You can just get out and do the same thing.
It doesn't matter.
I've just been doing it for the, uh, you know, flavor.
So he doesn't take it or you blind it.
Better.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
There's no like magical darkness in one piece.
I'm gonna take a selfie.
There.
He succeeds.
Just shot.
Touch your face.
Take fucking damage.
Uh, oh, that's not bad.
Take eight.
So he's resistance of thunder.
Fuck you.
He's the flavor to, uh,
of course he's resistance to thunder.
Take is gonna not be prepared for fighting fucking sin.
Okay, so half of 18 and nine and then half of that is
four.
Four again.
There we go.
Uh, concentrating.
He succeeds a concentration.
Okay, T-Gore, it's your turn.
You took the damage.
What are you gonna do?
You're blinded by the way.
So any attack you do on him is going to be with this advantage.
I'm gonna attack him unless.
Well, you could have attacked first and then move out.
Oh no, you take a second.
Well, he's not affected by his things.
He's gonna stay in there.
Let's see.
It's gonna move with him by the way.
Okay, I should have said this.
I should have said this.
Come on, it's a bomb.
What the fuck do you expect?
Do you mean follow rules?
No, no, where's the fun in that?
Come on.
Okay.
I can't use any spells while I'm wild shaped.
The only thing I can do is.
No, no, you can.
In your spellbook, go.
No, there is.
I need it to have.
You can't use spells when you're wild shaped.
Oh, fuck, I forgot.
Actually, the code is just a kind of costume.
Yeah, I mean, I don't care.
Here's a guy in the costume.
That's true.
Fuck me, spell, okay.
Yeah, you spell, I don't care.
I didn't expect you not to use spells.
I didn't go and you're expecting you not use spells.
Well, I was plucked by the rules.
Yeah, okay.
Get about the rules.
Oh, come on.
Do you want things to be called?
Do you want to be a rule fucking inspector?
Yeah, just by already.
Yeah, okay.
What happened if I make like home brew spells, huh?
What the fuck happens then?
Just because I use spells with.
Yep, I let you do home brew shit all the time.
Don't fucking talk back to me.
I am.
Okay.
Uh, 22 hits.
If I started out of the area, I mean, jump.
Yeah, you should you should be able to spot him where he is.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's the damage for that.
Ooh, nice.
Uh, Tigger, you spot him.
You are all, uh, you're on your four legs as you just leap in and just strike him right
in his face.
Uh, at spring on a hit, the target takes advantage.
And the next attack roll you make against it has a advantage.
So has it a manager?
Cool.
No, but I fought in the freaking darkness to get this.
Uh, we save concentration.
We save, of course.
That hits.
Uh, okay, four.
Nice.
Good try.
But it might not come out of concentration or it doesn't.
Okay.
Um, never mind.
Bardic, you can use, you can't use it on damage rolls, right?
No, you, the vampire was so I get my 10 HP back to four, but I didn't know.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
It's the things turned.
And he is going to make a, uh, deck safe for yourself first.
You'll take more damage when you're inside.
Did he succeed his consane for the second attack too?
Yeah, yeah.
Jesus.
You succeed.
Uh, as these like static electricity just jumps from one rod to another.
It barely touches you, but it does not damage you.
Um, all right.
It's his turn and he is going to just target you.
He does not seem to have any like, uh, consciousness at this point.
He's just looking at what he can see and just attack.
Um, he normal.
That's going to be six, which is not enough to knock you out, right?
Come on, safe.
Combat inspiration.
Yeah, yeah.
So if you want to add,
it was an attack world, but he was doing something else.
Uh, he's going to attack again with natural weapons.
And that's 10.
Yeah, that's this going to knock him out, right?
All right, T goes down.
What?
Hold on.
Are you using an attack or the hunger of a dog right now?
Attack.
It's up there.
Natural weapons.
If you see it, 14.
So it was that and the hunger of the dog that was happening on the same time.
No way, what is this?
Okay, so six.
Let me go back to the damage log man.
I'm so confused.
You took six damage.
And then what did I roll?
And then roll it again.
Yeah, in my bed, I'm going to roll again with natural weapons.
Natural weapons.
Oh my god, seriously.
Okay, attack.
I'll remove the last damage.
Uh, do damage.
And then I'll do this one.
Does it hit?
20 hits.
It's a sort.
I didn't see it.
Six.
Yeah, it still knocks you out.
All right, he goes down as he starts to move towards URIF
and the cloud of the daggers and the statics starts to move with him.
That makes me out of wild shape.
Oh, yeah.
But you are down.
Like you would be like knocked out so he would not pay attention to you essentially.
That's fine.
Do you want to attack him?
Do you want to approach your attack?
I mean, you can do that.
I'm still blind, so it'd be a disadvantage.
I'm still going to make the attack.
All right, go ahead.
Disadvantage.
Does it?
No, no, no, let me check.
Yeah, does it?
As you embed these claws as he's walking away from you and you slice like a part of his leg.
And he just starts ignoring you.
As soon as he saw you down, he just starts walking towards RIF.
All right, there you go.
Do I just transform to transform back?
No, how do I transform back?
Oh, let me, let me, there's like a arrow on your sheet right at the top, restore transformation,
near like a med kit I call it.
You see it?
There you go.
All right, he saves the concentration, the thing is still in the area and that's going to be the end of his turn.
But you're going to take the damage for.
And I'm down again.
Thank, let me check.
Uncle of a door.
Let me check how much damage it does before he goes down.
Well, it's more going to be at least two times.
So it's at least one.
Okay, how much is we do have?
Oh, you have one again.
Yeah, you're down again.
Okay, let's move on to the other fights, shall we?
Let's go to Baptiste.
Back in my fucking goal.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You still stay here because it's still him.
It's still him still alive.
So as soon as you go down Riff, he starts walking back towards the center as he sees a T-Gore stand up.
All right.
Now T-Gore is just like.
Yeah.
And he the thing just grows back at you.
I still have another use of wild shape.
You can't have a go back.
Do you have a different mask?
It has like a meaner eyebrows.
He's doing it.
All right, do it again.
It's meaner T-Gore.
You start your turn in the area.
So make a.
It's not letting me go.
It's feeling only be modified by GM or assistant.
What?
I don't know.
It's not letting me do anything with the character.
What transformation wise?
I see you transform.
Okay, let me do.
There you go.
It's done.
Action.
First take some Dimash.
Let me do the Dimash for you.
2D6.
Oh my god.
4.
It's gonna be 16.
There we go.
Damn.
Who knew T-Gore was gonna stick through.
He's following his new orders.
All right.
You have no bonus.
No bonus.
All right.
It's the things turn.
And at the end of your turn,
you also take 2D6.
So I'm gonna roll that for you.
Well, that's a first.
Yeah, that's safe.
That's a place.
I still have inspiration.
Yeah, you do.
Okay, I don't need it.
I need it.
No, no, you're fine.
I think you know, you need 14.
You still take half, right?
Or do you not take any?
Okay.
All right.
That's his turn.
And he is just going to look down at you.
The rods flying around are going to concentrate.
And they're going to shatter.
You know, make a con save.
He's in the area.
But no, it doesn't work on him.
Yeah, sure, one on.
He want to damage him as well.
Sure, one on.
I don't think it's going to change anything personally.
Just going to die.
Yeah, let me 1D8.
Again, that's one more.
11.
Let me bring him down to whatever he.
Concentration still up as the shockwave shatters.
You see his skin starts to ripple away as like the layer of his skin becomes like more
and more brittle as he's starting to fall apart at this point.
And Tegor, at this point, you also take like these shock waves after shock waves of sound blasts coming towards you.
It's your turn, Tegor.
And can you please take more damage?
Which is 10.
That will knock me out of wild safe.
And then 5 more damage to your normal thing, right?
9.
There we go.
What's like this deal?
Okay.
Okay, you have your turn.
Because I need to have a regular attack.
Okay.
The thing is centered around here.
You don't take damage.
Okay.
All right.
Hey.
What are you doing?
I did mess up.
What are you going to do?
I was going to do the cat spring again, but he more than 10 feet away.
Um.
So here's the thing.
Okay.
But you have to take the end damage to remember that.
Wait.
We're going to get our band peer clause back up.
All right.
What that word?
Just click when pre clause select him.
Apply.
Okay.
Who does care?
I'm actually tired of him, but I don't see.
He's assuming that he's here.
He's tired of that.
He's assuming that.
Who does care?
I know.
Okay.
Does not.
Does not hit.
That's not your inspiration.
What the fuck?
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't hit.
But this is here.
This is your what?
It would be over.
He's not that tough.
This HP is not that great.
Is that my turn?
Yeah.
You can do another like unarmed or the clause if you want to.
But this advantage.
Ooh.
Yeah, that hits.
Okay.
I think you can use the vampiric clause damage for this one.
So I can also get the heal.
So that's.
And for temporary HP.
Why is it trying to make him cast the spell again?
I have no idea.
I'm just going to add the four hand points.
Yeah.
Just do it manually.
Do the damage for the clause?
It would be over.
I don't see it.
Where did you roll it?
It's right above that spring.
Oh, vampiric clause, your rope vampiric clause.
Me, roll the concentration, your own man.
He's not dropping the concentration on this thing.
All right.
He will.
You will take damage, right?
Roll on the 20.
Sorry, not one D.
What was it?
2d6?
I have to do a deck safe first to see if I take.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do a deck safe.
Oh, it doesn't roll that high.
You don't.
Plast damage.
There we go.
Oh, you just lost your 10 HP.
That's fine.
That's going to be his turn.
He's going to walk towards you first.
You are close to him, right?
You literally on him.
He is going to...
He's out of spell slots for once.
He's going to natural weapon.
Tag normal.
And then natural weapon again.
23 heads, right?
15 heads.
Normal.
And normal.
8 and 4.
Woo!
How are you still fucking alive?
What is that?
18 and 12.
So that's 0 and then 11, right?
So you are 3 HP.
In the area, it's your turn.
So take 26.
So it doesn't matter.
Nine.
You're done.
What?
No, nothing.
All right.
Let's move to Baptiste.
And I'll come back to Malthus.
Okay.
Really?
Yeah.
For whatever reason, the token on the...
Yeah, there's two tokens.
I don't know why.
The one that's in there right now doesn't.
There's a lot of things.
I don't know how many we copied.
How many there are.
So I'm going to go back to Baptiste.
Okay.
Malthus, I wanted to say this is how it will go.
I will go to Baptiste.
Then we'll go back here.
So just stay here.
Okay.
All right.
Baptiste, I'll see you.
Oh, fine.
Hey, where are you?
I'm coming.
Okay.
All right.
Baptiste.
What were you doing last time?
All right.
For God.
I knocked the dude into the wall after doing all that damage.
Yeah.
It's in to level up.
Okay.
As you're walking, who word him?
Do you want to grab the thing?
Yes.
I like the security.
Okay.
As you're walking toward him, you reach down with your like literally half your body or like a hole in your body as the blood starts to pull more and more as the blood trails behind you.
You bend and try to grab the key from his neck.
And you feel a palm.
Stop you.
He's not dead.
He's not unconscious.
He just grabs your wrist.
And he is going to take a dagger from his actual plane.
He just snaps you.
Wait.
Oh, my face is cut removed.
It doesn't matter.
I think you're going to.
Yeah.
All right.
That knocks you out.
Let me move to Memphis.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I'm not going to be able to do this.
yeah he's just gone. Uh Tighor. As you are standing up to fight back with the
thing again, a PVC pipes right appears right below you, as you slide down it. And you
just end up at the base of it. And on the other side, you see this guy standing,
right in front of you as he goes.
What?
What's the cure?
He pulls out the key that he grabbed from a riff.
What the fuck?
He'll like find a grab it from him because he doesn't even know if the moon is out there
and he's just thinking.
Yeah, he goes. It's well. Um, all right, you say put as well. I'm gonna stay put with you.
Yeah, let's just set a stock. Okay, so, um, my name is close to all. How about you?
Kade. Kade. Kade hunt. Nice to meet you. Um, I, I, I'm not too sure what I'm supposed to
do, but the captain said you're supposed to help. How can I help? I think I've helped you.
I'm going to this. You take this one, one more. Uh, just stab it in your neck. It will
fix you right up. It's Captain Special Brand. Uh, are you gonna do that?
If it gives me back in the fight to kill that thing once in a while, no, no, no, no,
what do you mean? What do you want to fight that thing? I think scary. I think it's great.
You're one of those crazy people. Well, your friend is right here. If you follow me, uh,
yeah, just stab yourself with it. Uh, do you want to roll 68? Yeah. You just make sure
you're rolling. And it's paid. Mm hmm. What's it's still going to say about T-Swatch? Who
is? Yeah. Uh, all right. So you heal 20, uh, and you get 11 temp. Yeah. That's why you
get 11. Oh, yeah, yeah, you're in 12 12 12. Yeah. You're right. All right. He he makes like
another like the PVC pipes at this point extend more and he tells you to follow him. Uh, you
see like the back wall that you were lying against with just disappears as you fall down
and you just see those two walking toward you inside the PVC pipe like not walking like,
you know, crawling kind of, uh, not crawling, I guess, crouching and moving forward. Right.
Um, so I guess now we just wait. Oh, yeah, I forgot to, okay. I'm not too sure about that.
See, I like my safety. I like whatever you people have the disease off. So if you want
to fight, I'll send you right back up if you want to. Yeah, fine. I'd hear. I have a missing
thing. You know what? I like your spirit. I'm gonna, I'm gonna help you out from the shadows.
How about that? All right. One order coming right up as he lifts both his arms as this PVC
pipe appears right below you and just smacks you right upside. And you appear right in front
of this thing. It seems to have dropped the, uh, he'd our thing and both of you appear
on the opposite side of this thing. And you see like a small PVC pipe peeping from below
and you see just dravos looking and like peaking towards you guys from below and he gives
you a thumbs up. Go get him. All right. Uh, it's a T-Gore your turn.
Yeah, that is.
So I'm gonna get the multi attack when I'm transformed. Yeah, you only get the multi
attack when you're transformed. All right. Next, it's going to be the thing again and he's
going to look at you and looks a bit confused, but he nonetheless tries to attack you. Both
of the times he's going to hit you, but at the same time, dravos will do where is he?
Where the fuck is? There you go.
I'm going to you will hit him. Oh my god. Come on. Just do the DC. Okay. Sometimes it works.
Sometimes it doesn't work. Oh, he's saying it's nice. Uh, let me cut to him. Okay, when
the weapon heads, the creatures are strained by the web. It shouldn't keep sure this escape
from the web on success. Okay, so I just needed to do the save. He's not strained.
Basically, what happens is like dravos puts up his hands again and a bunch of PVC pipes
from all around the floor and from the roof. Just start and try to hold this thing back
as he's trying to hit, but unfortunately he cannot do that for some reason. He's going to
damage. For his, forces eight, the second is eight damn 16. So that's going to be four
damage to you overall. Alright, next is riff.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
is
a
as you go the rubber shotgun at this time shoots him in the back but this time you see
like the skin of this guy starting to like literally break apart as this rubber shotgun
just goes straight in right through the chest goes straight through his art and just the
rubber shotgun bounces off of T-Gore as this thing just falls flat down on the floor and
blood starts to like pull with like this green liquid seeping out of it and you see
since starting to transform back into his original form but it's all wrinkly and shit
okay as you slide in and grab him
he is dead laying in your arms
well I'll gently lay him down and close his eyes
okay as you do that you hear dravos getting out of the pipe he goes wow that wasn't as
hard as I thought it was good work friends now let's let's wait for the others to finish
I do want to head up I personally don't want to because you know trouble upstairs
now can someone fill me in as to what's happening
I'm going to like look at my pockets to see where the fuck it is
oh yeah yeah the thing actually when you collapsed I grabbed it you know that it's for them
okay as all if you start to get up you just leave synth there
riff yeah yeah you just leave synth there lying on the floor
okay and you start to climb up the ladder now all right let's go to mouth
this right and then I'll go to baptize all right all right the baptism I'll catch up go wait in level one all right I'm here let me move you to the
green line green line all right what was the last move that he did I went down you know no the guy did
he just kept bonking you right that's it and with the paladins last hit you were down for the count all right
all right the next part is basically going to be these guys introduction and that's it today for today that's going to be it for next time I'm gonna
I was waiting on my level of mid combat that's gonna be that's gonna be next it's gonna be next session
yeah they've already ran from far too long it's like 2 a.m. for me man let me go no it's gonna be it's gonna be cool believe me trust me trust me trust me
but then I wouldn't have done it on my own no no you are going to do it on your own they're gonna like kill him like
drabos didn't kill the guy you guys did they are going to intervene but now they're not gonna like fight him fight him what you're not gonna know
you know you're not gonna kill him what do you mean but you said level of mid combat go back to foolishly yeah
but I have to narratively make it make sense you can't just level up for no reason with like no like how do
you recover your resources key points stuff like that you know as it's fine it's fine no one's no one's no one's stealing your
thunder man chill chill yes he is who is the fucking base guy casting shadows left on the right oh as he's going to finish
you off a PVC pipe essentially appears right but you don't see it of course no you see it you you see it sorry
sorry I got confused PVC pipe appears right behind base and figure jumps out and lands right in
front of him as he's trying to hit you he will go sorry sorry sorry sorry and I go point of having
extended figure break fishermen karate break fist and he's going to essentially push him back a bit
as this it lands on him the guy slides back around like 10 feet and he walks around and you hear like
these muffled voices of another voice like land right behind you and he just goes it doesn't look that
great might not be able to fix him and the fish guy that landed right in front of you goes
captain's orders nothing we can do just fix him up and get him back to us how long do you think it's
gonna take this guy is pretty big I thought it would take 30 seconds but considering the damage
he's had might even take a whole minute can you hold him off for one whole minute I guess I
gotta try no no he walks up to this guy and they both take a stance and that's where your
consciousness will fade away all right that's it for today sorry it might not you know if you
survived you would be able to transform but he didn't survive so you're not you know unfortunate
all right I'm gonna finish up with that piece then we're gonna have a little check and
lunar fall and then we're gonna do this next session bye bye hello hello let me go back to
Estral Plain. Estral Plain please thank you all right as the dagger essentially just
goes straight through your heart killing you you fall down like back on your back bleeding out
from essentially your side and at this point the dagger just stuck in your heart and this guy
starts to get up and he goes he spits out the blood with all the like broken ribs and like
essentially his arm is completely broken so he he's just limping through and towards you
sits crouches right around you it was the one who was disappointed now you piece of shit he takes
another dagger out of that space and this time he's just aiming for your head
and as soon as he starts to do that uh PVC pipe of PVC pipe appears oh my god
what is happening
sorry wrong one
there you go
now it's gonna be fine okay as this PVC pipe appears right above you
baptizes you see it uh you see the the size of this pipe is very large and as
you see the pipe appear in front of you a figure lands right on top of you looking at you
grabs you pushes the other guy like with one hand just smacks him and that guy just lands on the
other side of the room it grabs you puts you against the wall it looks you around he tabs you
yes aren't you looking rough buddy well i guess we begin wax uh you see around his neck there's like a
small monkey and this guy seems like pretty huge it's like even bigger than a mouthfuls and he
just puts you in a corner he uh laps his arms you see the uh tattoos on on the right side of his
arm starts to turn from blue to like a deep red as this trail of blood starts to drop down his
fingers as he will cast uh there we go no sorry not this what is it crimson right you most
aces uh as soon as he says that the blood from his arm starts to pull around you and your blood
as well starts to gather towards you as you are put inside this like cocoon where it's basically
like reconstructing your body you feel his arm like going over like this cocoon shape and you hear
like a muffle the voice through it oh that's weird i see a bone structure that
why does he have it then no mine i think it might take more than 30 seconds to prepare
60 seconds it is all right you come uh and uh i'm gonna end it here for today
what
hello i know everyone is pissed at me what is wrong what happened
you promised a level of myth combat you are leveling up making mit combat the fuck do you think
is happening it's not epic though it is epic come on your people showed up to help you
oh it's gonna be epic come on you what do you mean you didn't okay first of all i i
the first of all the the NPCs beat you straight forward what did you prefer to happen they kill you
yes oh my god come on i don't know
bro both of you were killed what do you read
and then look you told us if when we level up mid combat we will first get to next thing that's what i said
i feel like it's a level up that she said i worked my ass off to figure out how it will work
mid combat how the level up with my mid combat i have to write it in the story to make it make
sense you can't just level up mid combat for no reason bro that was the whole thing you were supposed to
happen what do you mean i have to write these cultures and you have to understand it's not it's not
i can't just do it yes you can come on what is so lame if i was oh suddenly you have your all your
HP help all your stats back or everything come on
okay all right well i thought it would be cool but i guess not
that's it it's the bloatoree bow it could have been better should have done it on our own
you are doing it on your own it's not like they're helping i didn't use dragoes to fight them
i'm not gonna use any of the others to like damage them at all it's basically that except for the
flavor everything you're worried about is the flavor they're not gonna help you if that's what you're
worried about think about it in an anime style so yeah all of these fights are one-on-one right yeah
all of a sudden we quote unquote go down yeah and someone else comes into help us by
killing them so whatever killing killing who is no longer a one-on-one fight can you get it
yeah if they might as well okay okay okay think think think think about this okay
luffy goes down right what happens then so anime push it on he gets back up
yeah exactly what that's what's happening to you what do you mean
oh my god i swear to god bro like look okay malphous one of the guy is going to just heal you the
other guy is just going to hold him off 60 seconds it's only 60 seconds do you understand in anime
time that's nothing that's the whole as i would have everything i know it's in dnd time it's
in a whole s hour but in anime time it's nothing it's just like blocking him off it's just
running away defending you that's it and for uh baptism cases the same
but here's what could have happened you could have knocked this out but you have like a dream sequence
where it's like you can't give up yeah bro you're not gonna fucking magically fix the fucking
holding your body no you can bro you're in like full on like a fucking like a voom essentially
you're being reborn how cool is that i was in my elemental body so i can just restore the
element in that section of my body to restore that part i just got spanked by a hammer right good
up charge myself like oh all right well i tried i guess i won't do it again
when i don't okay next time you know what fucking figured out you're gonna die you're gonna die
i don't care yeah i'm done i'll have my back of anyway i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i don't care
bro i was thinking so much how would i make them go from there to there and then how would
i make them go from there to there how would i make it make sense and now you're just telling me
it's all bullshit at least i knew it now instead of all four people telling me it's bullshit
i'm gonna go to stay the same okay look what's that about to say come
if i would have known there was a second stage to the fight i won
in all of that in i just give that there's no second stage to the fight he didn't go down
i had three stairs he has he has more health oh okay let me tell you
mouth is how how much health he's at he got knocked out he got knocked out knock down it's not
the same as fucking dying his HP and he's got conscious go down this is okay okay
it's the same same knocked out as lufi right right all right guys i mean technically we're not that
when we go to zero yeah yeah but you can get back up with with something but you don't need
anything because they're not like it zero HP okay i'm gonna tell you malphous right now he was
more than a half HP the guy you were fighting there was no way you could have beaten him
i refuse to believe it we knew going into this that there were gonna be tough fights we knew
get out yeah and you're gonna get the same chance all i'm doing is adding flavor all i'm doing
is just giving you the time you need to heal up get leveled up while you're in that state of
healing up and then you can fight i don't know what the fuck deal is you're gonna pull out the
race to match people oh my god i mean moves on where i suddenly like hey they have a speed boost
off like for the fuck hey here's next to you now okay let's just say oh you okay okay let me
say you're saying the the haste thing no wait i'm just gonna say hmm we did this this week so you'd
have more time next week yeah do bob in wrong yeah now there's a whole another part of our fight
so we're gonna does that mean bob and roma are gonna have to do another session the week after next one
to no no no next week's gonna be like five hours right we haven't been here for five hours
so roma and bob are gonna have the first phase of the fight they're gonna have the same sequence
with different people and then there's gonna it depends right if they go down before the
second part of the fight if they go down after the second part of the fight who knows well then
it gonna go down they said it's fucking bob please go fighting one show it probably uh anyway
it's gonna happen for both of them the same way then you guys are gonna come in and you know
we have the we already had the thing and then we're gonna continue to the second part so they're
not gonna skip a week i'm just gonna tell them what happened in this whatever time frame it takes
them to recover i think bob is gonna be the only one excited that he gets help in the fight
yeah no one no one's gonna help again i'm telling you right now no one's gonna help
they're here to do a job and then go away if bob's guy doesn't help bob is gonna be bad
i don't fucking care i feel like bob is in his whole fight trying to convince the other guy to help
in fight bob's gonna spend his whole fight commencing convincing the enemy to stop your scammility
i'm not used to this this is what i do all right you know i fuck you from now on
you're one on one you want one on one i'm gonna give you one on one fuck you
it's not the one on one that's the problem no no i see it you want true one on ones right
i do you really think you can make it work in dnd true one on ones it's no one
when you okay if we did get our level up mid five like you said we were in full heal i could have
okay okay let's try okay you tell me then how how am i supposed to write this in how
what i how am i supposed to make it make sense okay so you wanted essentially a back story thing
that essentially gives you all your HP how would i make you like fix it
it's a good thing when people are dying i certainly
all right okay okay because there was only two ways i could have done it and easily yesterday
up until yesterday i was thinking oh it's fine they'll survive right surely surely they're not
gonna die as soon as the level up no no no exactly i knew you were you were dying but then i was like
if i don't heal them back up to my xhp they are going to die the second one let's say like in case
of baptism you were at twhp if even if you were able to take him down at that point with the
twhp what would have happened you would have leveled up you would have fought him more i guess
but even a single hit would have taken you down so the only way i could balance it is heal you to the
max to heal you to the max i can't just say you had a flashback and now you're at full hp
right do you see what this is the world of fantasy anything you think
oh my god come on we gotta stick to the rules for something
i would always stick to the rules okay what what what did i what did i break okay tell me what did i
break did i i can literally choose any other spell other than arms of hader that will have the
same effect and you're not you're gonna stop complaining and i had haste on his sheet do you want to see
his sheet the guy he's complaining about the guy suddenly like dropped all of his stuff and ran
after him and that's how he got his speed back up and that's that's a problem
yeah that's the bro haste literally does the spell what do you mean
oh hey i think it doesn't give me a speed oh yeah the tower speed is level but that's still
yeah
i've learned i've learned my lesson i'm not gonna do when one we once from now on i'm just done
no i like the one we want no no you don't no you don't make that fucking possible
but you beat make that fucking possible you're fighting your bosses how do i make bosses possible
for players to fight that's not how we do it next bro okay
mouth is tell tell me one thing if that guy didn't land that one hit on you would you spend all
your fucking turn just running away or not how is that cool i know that's your whole thing but how
that's not cool that's not cool for a one we won i know that's your style i didn't even fly
yeah i know you didn't fly but what uh hell was it gonna change
just leave the one thing i'm not gonna allow i will be the only one that does want to be once
as the captain i'll be the lucky and you're the only one that takes the one be one everybody else can do
group fights okay maybe maybe i should take the criticism at this point i think i might have
fucked up it's fine it's fine i expected it to go bad because i knew i haven't done anyone
we ones and i i don't know i have no idea how to work one we want to be in the
so it's a learning experience we'll fix it i'll fix it if you guys are not happy with it i might
tweak it for next time i have to come up with something i guess uh but what what is happened has
happened we can't change that right
didn't i feel great about my one be one
hmm yeah your one who one was fucking insane bro
oh what it lasted for what three routes four rounds it max i don't know let me go
it had check it went for five rounds it went for five rounds you fucking killed the guy like
one round essentially two rounds or whatever three four yeah five rounds
but yeah and one of the rounds you were fucking uh held right
i was essentially you were yeah so there's just four rounds and you were just fucking
knocked them essentially i think you just have this health in one move in one round i think
pretty sure
oh i think what i was crazy the issue was is that going into it we were under the assumption like
oh we're getting a level up and max hp mid fight so we we don't know how you're doing
yeah i guess i guess i worded it a wrong way i get it i get it it's about that like
when i went down to two hp i was like oh this is perfect because i just feel good
okay if you guys want a more stricter
way of fighting NPCs if you want like to stick to the rules i'll do that
but then you'll have to stick to the rules which is which does mean that no bulge your
devil fruit powers are fewer asses from now on give me a set list of uh devil fruit powers
and that's that's gonna be your spell list and we have to fix it then you have to fix it the
the amount of spells you can prepare isn't that also what i've been doing this whole time i know i
know but i'm talking about teeth and everyone else
well i have a set list i just know you don't you just say oh i i'm gonna use this
what do you mean you have i just don't use my set list exactly so i can start using that
we want if we wanted the same experience for NPCs then we have to stick with the same rules for
PCs i'm making like a hardline thing here i'm just saying or i don't know i don't know i feel like
some NPCs have to have like custom action you can't make it work i just don't feel like it works
the same way flaving wise too you can do what you need to do to make the NPCs tougher
just it's um this day is like an ability of theirs
and make it an ability what is a spell a spell is an ability
no like a special ability for them like he does exactly that's how this is how like most of the
devil's foods work right every devil's food that you guys have also have like
flavoring to it i mean of course it doesn't change the rules but still
stone favorite it doesn't it does change the combat a bit even if like the damage type is different
and i'm level up right now and do the second part of my fight
no we don't have time it's to him for me man what do you mean
yeah you i said it because of you you sorry you want to start two hours early i would have started
two hours early i don't care you you ask me so i assume you want to start two hours later
i okay i okay the way that i worded it was if you want we can start two hours later than usual
in consideration of you you didn't say if you you said you want to start two hours later than usual
yeah that's why i tagged you personally not mouthless and you
i assume y'all had already agreed on the two hours no i didn't know oh my god oh it was just that i
was like i just read it
soar is like oh if that's what we're gonna have to do then yeah but it's not a
please
all right i'll send something in downtime action or i'll i guess i have to DM you
well i'll DM you the things that happen after you boats are being fixed
and then you'll pick up your side of things once we're almost in bobs thing is done
so i don't know what you want to do in the meantime i already told you it's a bad idea
so you want to just sit back and do nothing while that is happening
we're gonna take time i was fine with it today i was just like
but yeah but for today it was like i was switching in between and you had like two
roles to play at the very least then it would be just me hopping into rumours chat
me hopping into bobs chat and that's it for like i don't know maybe a couple of hours
i'll be fine you couldn't let us back date
okay i guess you want to spectate you can spectate
all right so i can predict how it almost flies it's gonna go but i'm just excited like confused
about bobs coming too
for Roma i have something to say i just gonna be like oh i rage huh i go hit
huh i just for i hit more huh yeah but the see these arenas that you guys were in were not really
like very environmental heavy but the other two are going to be because the characters that
they're fighting so it's gonna be a bit more complicated so we just got the short end of the
stick no you didn't what what the hell what the hell do you want to do the the main guy that you're
fighting does not really think you're much of a threat the tremor guy is does not think anyone can
go through his arm in any way so he doesn't care okay uh yeah but that's the point there you
have to prove it but if you if you really think this is the end oh i don't know what to tell you
you
i thought you guys had wild shit that's why i was like oh you guys have a bigger health pool
no but oh fuck oh fuck i actually expected at least mouthless to like beat the first phase of the
his guy but he didn't so my face was back through the beginning
did you not transform yeah i did but it did it did it's more than one head
he did more than one head than i have a damage beat yeah he has extreme tags you know does that also
has a trick extreme tags
had like three attacks but it's fine i mean he can also just miss like you
one out of like 12 attacks yeah my fucking i'm in the other mind i'm getting
i missed a lot of my attacks too yeah initially and then on the fuck me last one that mattered you
fucking blew it apart without using your inspiration that's crazy the first roll that's
fucked my fucking whole run yeah the second roll the first one dead hit i remember the second
roll didn't well no the first roll was a table oh yeah the fucking table bro any creature that he
attacks he will have a disadvantage or you will have a advantage on it if he attacks a creature
other than you he gets nothing nice there's no the creature was fucked from the beginning
yeah one round just wasted exactly no fortunately this is
now it is and i'm gonna send look i just wanted you guys to
get to know the other crew members is that too bad i guess it's too bad
i'm really gonna happen now
what nothing's gonna happen what
because that's just what's going oh he's all right peace out
no they're not gonna fucking go away they're just gonna sit back and watch that's it i think you
want to fight right i assume that yeah exactly i assume that's what would have i want you to act
like the characters that you are right now fucking attacking me but they don't attack me but they can
have me in here i didn't do shit all right uh when they show up uh basically what i'm expecting
you guys to do is just tell them to you know stay stay out of the fight and that's it
i was um i went on a mission with color or shock uh i think you went with the color
you would remember him but he's not paired up with you i guess he was paired who he is paired up with
i feel like it's Bob no there's only one more option no
i don't know if it has either so yeah yeah i get it i get it
no no not the crab he's uh he's the mantis shrimp
yeah i'll come on it's the crustacean yeah it's a crustacean but it's not the same thing
how do you feel when i say it this is the same thing i hope it's about these who cares
but i thought you know that he i thought you'd be happy to get your wings back but i guess not i'll
remove the wings you're going back yeah this is the first time hearing of it
both didn't he say that it's weird your bone structure suggests that there's something there
and i'll just reconstruct them yeah i just probably just meant that they're just not gonna be
he knew my wings were gone and they're just not going to be uh he did say at the end oh i guess i'm
gonna just reconstruct them it might take a while bro i have it on recording okay don't
fucking pull that shit on me you didn't hear it probably it might have not heard it but
i guess i guess everyone's annoyed at me everyone's mad at me
let's see i'm sorry what i'm gonna i'm gonna do a turn under the assumption that i leveled up
so that's that okay i actually tagged that's two i would have i actually tagged this gives you
okay let's see if you use all your key points like one of your key points to do one more attack
and then what attack where are you doing extra attack can you do extra attack and
spend one like one of the key points right you can right okay so uh flurry of blows is action right
or is it bonus it's a bonus so attack attack that's two then flurry of blows once that's one two
it's four attacks that's four attacks okay four attacks and if you hit every one of them that's
gonna give you at least 40 plus plus five five five right you do plus five right did you click
the attack as well no i didn't i didn't click shit did i present that many times yeah
delete all right um one that's more or your blows one two then i had it's plus 15 right so 15
four times is 60 and then a range of one d8 four times 48 plus 60 that's crazy bro that's insane
oh my god what the hell am i good oh god good damn it okay i believe these are all you this is
how many attacks i'd be able to make in one time let's just roll roll
roll you're just rolling the same one it shouldn't be yeah it is
it's okay i'm just gonna do the damage for them anyway that needs to have the balls up the way
yeah okay yeah it's kind of messed up i don't know what's happening
that's one that's two
did it messed it up again okay i'm not doing this
i'm gonna clear this actually all right there we go yeah i think something's broken
pretty sure all right well i guess fuck me this is an l for me personally i guess
i guess we'll figure it out as we go on
i was like oh you guys should get hyped about these new characters but no
oh we got hype on level look okay i hope roma doesn't feel the same way and boba i don't think
cares i'll get hype for new characters if i can recruit them to the crew
they're all recruited to the crew to mean exactly that's why i wasn't excited okay okay i see
i see i see it i see it now my bad i missed that caveat that they have to be
strangers yeah just random strangers that that should have done it
then he would get excited imagine if i just said like psych it's the is the six volts
okay would it would okay oh my god
how the sad thing i think the fucking difference wrong
because we know them and then they're like hey we come back for you bitch
did you know these people too i mean not now but you know these people
completely different if it was the six volts because you see this that it yourself all of them
have like a connection to us in our back stories yeah but these guys are also kind of connected in
your future stories right we should we should pay attention to the future stories too right
wait did if you met well you would attack him yeah
okay you know i'm i'm rethinking my whole fucking story i know but we'll see we'll see
all right i think you're scoring
uh i think that was some things i always like oh at some point you guys would
me back up with the six volts but i guess you could just write them out it's fine
oh no no i think i think it's fine i was joking
see i see okay if it was the six volts who would you want instead of the two with
melphous and one with you and one with one with one with t-gore and what's this face or feel like
where the six volts were attached to our back story should have been the one that came to help us
yeah the same ones that's attached to your back story so you wanted uh what's their face
Liz from melphous it would have been Klein which again still missing um
you could have been found okay sure sure that just happens
we don't know where he's at the six volts might know where he's at
again like uh when when did they leave like three days ago i think i don't think they could have
crossed the uh combelton three days um was them nations like
them what when zim was on the ship and we were getting information from her she said that um
verith was traveling with another member of the six volts but it wasn't Liz that she was talking
we're referring no no no no no she said it wasn't Klein that she was referring to
verith it does not go solo he's always with someone it's too much
you know i know i know it's been it's been a while like about two months since that happened so
i get it um
for melphous it would have been Klein for Roma it would have been if for Roma it doesn't make sense
because he you guys have not met this person yet and this person is not the version of him
yeah this person is not part of the six volts technically he's like in name still part of them
is not like really is he's is it's all
it wouldn't make sense and again the elephant was forced by for bob for bob again i have no one
for my poll yeah exactly no help bob gets in no help bob just dies uh for for the last one for those two
who would i send minus i guess what makes sense whale and cerica for the last one come on what would
they do fucking twittle on their thumbs what what what what what are they there for
just to watch i could just watch you yeah again see the the numbers yeah who
cerica is going to get an annual
now we're bringing bad Daniel for some reason my god the numbers don't match up guys come on
i need it six feet only the only way i could why would the spider come and help you don't
even know the spiders you know three of the spiders you don't know how they who they are how they
are you know Daniel for some reason Daniel's older brother whoever runs the fucking crew is working
with the doctor you don't know why he was working with the doctor you don't know if he knew about
what the doctor was doing you don't know if he's with them he was against them you don't know
anything about the six spiders what what are you making assumptions for people just fuck off
yeah exactly that's how that's how things work they they fuck off because the journey ended
what what reason did they have to stick around they already told you literally the
moment they get off the island they were like yeah find your own what fucking boy
let me know what happens to you like I know something weird what you want to do the fucking
turn is keep me kept like going and that's why I paused it
it doesn't fuck up the combat thing that's why oh what just just do the math just do the average
no okay that doesn't hit that doesn't hit doesn't count I'm assuming they hit okay
just do the math just do the average bro you want to count the max damage or what what are you looking
for oh by the way that mouthless we're doing because Baptiste used the crit rule that we set like
the first roll would be crit and the second one would be a normal roll so we're going with that
for now I don't want to hear shit about oh the NPC hit me for a least damage and why he's doing
with fucking max damage for the first rolls I don't give a shit I think it's rolling everything
wise for me no no I see everything 8 7 6 8 maybe 7 6 oh yeah yeah I don't know it's something's bugged
just reload just reload yeah all right for the next next week you guys are good right
yes it just it might be less salty then
don't it's a touchy subject right now don't don't do it yes do it it's always a picture so that this is
what
repeat or what the last time we fought me and him oh no they're my favorite not the balance because I
should have helped resistance yeah I don't know he shouldn't have resistance he shouldn't have
resistance no one should have everything but if you want to survive back to gas 3 don't don't worry don't
worry I'll I'll have a tournament arc at some point you know I've I've I've foreshadowed it right
already so the tournament arc is coming and it's not going to be just you guys for sure
just create a boss that only I can 1v1 no I'm done with that you're going to fight
player versus player matches that's it exactly how it's said in the sheet that's how it's going to work
sorry not the sheet the the source book the one piece source book that's how it's going to work
I just have to bring in fucking the rest of the bullshit with the fucking steps and whatnot
not less steps what what is called Roku Shiki and bring in the fucking sword techniques I'll just
I'll bring in the custom classes that's why I didn't want to do it because usually that the how I
make sheets is I level up the NPCs in the same classes pick the stuff from the classes but that
takes too long the takes like what okay if I tell you that all of this so far but honestly
the art bullshit side quest that I went on on wasn't necessary but I already did it so fucking
it doesn't matter that took a whole fucking day fucking foundry took a whole fucking day from moving
from a fucking server I was paying for to my own like local last barry setup that took a whole
fucking day and then one day I think I just just wrote for this thing and I have to write for the next
two combat oh god that's rough but for first for the first time you guys are like very adamant
about how much it did not like what happened for the first time I will I ask for feedback every session
and this is the only time I get like actual feedback it's crazy and I thought I was I was so hot
I was so hot doing this shit from 99 damage yeah you should have just done that I don't know why
you didn't do it like this can you do crit roll a crit if I do a crit that means it's 10 d8 correct
it's no no it's plus five times eight 99 plus five times eight
what yeah first roll would be max damage oh yeah yes all right I'll tell you if this would have
a been able to kill him like in one shot or not 99 plus five times why are you rolling five times
though who is the shouldn't be four five attacks because I had haste active oh oh oh oh I see how
does your haste work haste just gives me an extra action so that's just another point no but
how does your haste work in like the rules how does it does it increase your speed that's it
I cast haste myself using my cover fruit by what did I say I don't know I don't know what she said
let me play the gravity of the target to increase or decrease their streak so either haste or
slow I have a bunch of bunch of bullshit all right oh you agree to it I know I know in the you
don't the moment I agree to a lot of shit 139 that's yeah that would literally have one shot at
them that's crazy don't worry you'll get one more chance right to one shot him you really don't
think this is this is all right we know this is in all there's no the emperor no no no no no no no
I'm I'm talking about Koda the guy you were fighting do you think the fucking do you think he
what he can get a boost without help but we can't okay you want to you want to die like the last
guy you can get a boost you want that I'll change the whole story I don't care none of this is
can you want to change it let's do that okay first tell me how do you acquire the thing do you have it
did you take the serum the serum that you got on cholesterol
I don't know what we did with the stuff I'm going that was so long ago
yeah exactly I know that you took the serum you haven't done anything with it
I know the the character she does all fucked but you know it's my fault honestly I don't know
you can't even reach you exactly I mean you can use the serum I'm not
telling it not you so you can use it but you've seen what it does
twice you fought the chimeras back at hallows place like in the core and I mean if you want to do it
for sure why not just tell me what animal you want actually rollo 1d20 rollo 1d20
mouthfuls in love tees it's gonna be a marble so it's only going to be let me check my table actually
okay thank you man oh also when I get live my fighting style is going to change
what what's going to happen why would it change or text what you're going to do more attacks
be more strategic like almost the way I would have what it changed
oh I don't get it I get five punches yeah
to make the most out of those five punches I would have changed how I was attacking
oh you mean on our strikes yeah my first punch would have been stunning strike
oh I say yeah yeah makes sense makes sense try to get myself advantage for all of my
next attacks yeah exactly nice I don't worry if that works uh items
where's the fucking table there you go uh open and not bad what did you guys roll
do we level up our characters now or no no next time on dragon moldy uh you're all the 15
mouthfuls you can just roll roll discord for the animal that you're gonna get once you get the serum
what's the reason because that's what you prefer right okay
uh what do you roll 15 five no no about teased 15 and you are five okay
uh baptized you are going to be a stag and uh mouthfuls you're going to be chicken
so it doesn't change much look I'm not lying I have the fucking roll table right right in front of me
or just manage it's gonna be a bubble oh it's I think it's the older roll table you know I'll move
you I'll I'll move you two up it's a hedgehog so enemies take 1d4 damage if they grapple you spiky
and I know ram attack no stag is a mammal fuck off ram attack 1d8 presence boosts moral of allies
that's all the bonuses you get and the everything else is going to be the same you would have had
your HP restored you would have your spell slot restored and that's it none of the other things
would have been restored uh that is better you think okay I don't think that's better
I think leveling up is better with cool entrances but you know who am I
what flash flash you know what let's let's just for you guys I'm gonna plan for the next
small arc or whatever the fuck kind of arc we have right now whenever we have something like this
where I think you can take on one-on-ones with minimal help I'll do it for the flashback thing
but you were not gonna level up I'm just gonna restore your health or whatever the fuck you want
because it's not gonna work the same I think I don't know we'll see I'll try the flashback thing
that's all I'm saying I think flashback thing has merit I don't think any of the other
suggestions so far has met has any merit I agree with the flashback thing other than that no
Um...
So I gotta just read these people off now.
Alright, I'll see you guys next week.
- [inaudible]
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, no.
That's fine.
I thought you guys liked these...
You would like these characters, but I guess you don't know anything about them, so I should know.
- [inaudible]
- Exactly. I get it. I get it.
- How far are you?
- Yeah, I get it. I get it.
We'll see. Maybe you...
Uh...
If you talk to them, it makes...
A bit more.
Make it...
Make it harder, bit less. Maybe...
[laughs]
- [inaudible]
- If Bob and Roma like it, then you have two against two, so you...
- No!
No, it's fine.
You guys don't like it. I'm already sad about it.
What's done is done.
Nothing. Nothing changes now.
- So we're all sad now.
- Yeah, we're all sad now.
- We're all the best.
- Collective... Collective... Collective sadness.
Alright.
Mass depression, casted, successfully.
- Yeah.
- I'm out.
Bye-bye. [laughs]
I'll see you guys next week, but...
- Yes, we are.
(bells chiming)